it's been nothing but ukraine war russia
war ukraine man it's crazy there's other
stuff going on in the world but this one
does seem to be the most uh pressing we
do have the freedom convoy making its
way and we do have a bunch of other
crazy stories too but uh man i've been
looking back at all the news and it's
just endless talk of what's going on in
ukraine because obviously people keep
saying world war iii the latest russia
has apparently blocked access to
facebook so it's like as all these
companies say we're going to censor you
or sanction you russia is just like okay
get out we're done with this but it does
feel like russia is becoming
increasingly increasingly more isolated
because even china seems to be backing
off a little bit brazil and india are
kind of like yo we're neutral on this
one so i don't know if russia will be
able to hang out uh for for much longer
but i do think they may end up winning
at least their objectives here now
donald trump has come out and said he
told putin and she he would nuke them
if they went after ukraine or taiwan and
uh so basically he's confirming the
story which is crazy and then we've got
a bunch of other crazy stuff um
one thing i really want to talk about
tonight there's this ad i got on twitter
for an artificial intelligence like
girlfriend or friend it doesn't say
girlfriends it's friend and it's just
really creepy so i want to remind
everybody don't date robots
i'm featuring but we'll talk about that
too and we're going to talk about the
world economic forum critical race
theory with um none other than the
foremost expert on critical race theory
author of race marxism james lindsay
yeah
he's like yes yes all of those things
those things the world economic forum
yeah
yes uh what are you doing who are you
what's going on i'm somebody
you're a sword fighter i am a sword
fighter a little bit i mean we were
sword fighting a little bit like that
james
oh my gosh
james disarmed me i did uh with the
wakazashi
oh cool
that's right so you know keeping up with
things traveling a lot talking a lot
getting around the country being the
world's i guess foremost expert in
critical race theory as i've been billed
smeagol must take names that he's given
well it makes the show seem more
prestigious you know and i'm like this
guy's the best yeah the white guy is the
foremost expert in crt how offensive how
offensive i'm a non-practicing white
though
i don't believe in practicing my race
he's a lapsed white oh my god wait was
so are you like baptized white and then
just stop doing it or
fall away in your teens yeah i think
that's how that works raised white for a
few years but then you know left the
race
yeah like uh what's her face uh rachel
dolezal yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but no
she uh she tried to adopt another race i
just checked yeah she consisted she was
she converted i started clicking other
on all the boxes yeah yeah yeah i'm just
gonna check them out we got uh so what
what we'll be talking to james about a
lot of stuff uh we got to sheamus of
freedom too sheamus of freedom tunes
yeah i make cartoons i have youtube
channel called freedom tunes if y'all
want to check that out we released a
cartoon yesterday on joe biden's state
of the union and we're working on some
tunes next week about the industrial
military complex as well as the woke
military training so i think you guys
will like that go there subscribe stay
tuned and also really excited for
tonight's show
uh ian crosslin over here nothing too
deep to report yet but i am on board and
reporting for duty i am stoked as well
because james knows how to talk and he
knows what he's talking about it's gonna
be a great conversation tonight we love
having james yeah i'm kind of tired so
i'm just gonna be like
just just tell us everything i'm gonna
sit back here and get my phone i got
i've been playing lemmings right now
dude lemmings is that's are you kidding
me it's one of my favorite games yeah it
was amazing yeah the game was amazing
but the mobile and emulated version no
no the mobile version is weak yeah it's
like you can make stairs ah dude we have
a sega genesis downstairs i know i'll
get one of the cars you guys need to mod
that and get the mpc faces on the limits
yes oh that's cool that's amazing no for
real i could do that in 20 minutes they
support all the things so just falling
off the cliff
that's actually that's a brilliant idea
actually we're not paying you for that
but we will use it
we should make a game yeah where it's
like kind of like lemmings but it's npcs
yes so for those of you know what
lemmings is you like 30 little lemmings
will walk around and do just like walk
back and forth and you can assign tasks
to them so like dig a hole or block
someone or like you know shoot rope
across a gap or something paint black
lives matter on a street yeah yeah yeah
unattended they just keep walking until
they die yeah you gotta try and guide
them to the right exactly so they just
walk in and the idea is you have to get
them from the entrance to the exit of
the level
with as few as possible dying it's a
great game it's really a great mobile
version is really weak because in the
original game there was like 20
different jobs you could give them and
in the mobile version there's like four
oh yeah i mean there's actually maybe
like seven or eight yeah it's
it's very strategic because you have a
limited number of jobs you can assign so
like on some levels there can only be
like three climbers or two diggers it's
awesome lemming is a fun game we should
make it npcs all right before we get
started talking about you know more
serious stuff but probably not go to
timcast.com become a member help support
the work of all of our journalists as
well as everyone on this show we are
principally supported by website
memberships you know uh we started the
site a year ago just over a year ago and
it was funny because the longest time i
was like we rely too heavily on youtube
on ads and that is a huge weakness
especially with activists going crazy
and so we we set up the website which
has become our main uh way that we fund
and maintain this operation which gives
us a lot of leeway and provides us that
safety net and it also allowed us to
create an editorial department where we
write articles and do our own sourcing
and our own fact checking and our
original reporting so it's all thanks to
you plus we've released books and a new
show called pop culture crisis so if you
want to support our work and check out
members only shows from the tim castro
podcast go to timcast.com but don't
forget to smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends yo let's talk about
this year censorship we have the story
from the guardian russia blocks access
to facebook and twitter oh man good the
move to block facebook and twitter comes
as the government passed a bill that
criminalizes fake reports against the
war
you know what's funny i'm not a fan of
censorship for the most part you know i
think it's obviously there's nuance here
censoring some stuff is important and
good like we talk about child abuse
criminal acts and stuff that's where the
sensors are really supposed to be like
okay that is crime like against children
and humanity get rid of it but um when i
see russia banning facebook and twitter
i get i feel like like this kind of
catharsis of like i wish i wish just get
rid of it i know it's so i hate it so
much but it is truth be told twitter and
facebook are still pretty good despite
all of the bad and therein lies the real
challenge the ability for regular people
to actually have a voice even if they do
face censorship and that's why we resist
the censorship here because the power
granted to the people by these platforms
was good and now they're trying to take
it back because they realize they made a
mistake
well
i'm generally against censorship i
generally agree with what you just said
the only really kind of interesting
thing i don't know that it's even
directly connected to this the only
really interesting thing that i
think i tweeted this this morning i
think people got really mad about it is
that one of the utilities of facebook
and in particular more than twitter but
twitter has this too is if if you have
some controversial narrative thing going
on some controversial activity whether
it's ukraine whether it's a virus
whether whatever it is
one epistemological tool to sound very
philosophical that's emerged in the past
few years is whatever facebook will ban
is probably true yes so if you want to
find out what's going on with ukraine or
with a virus or with the world economic
forum or whatever it is
or is it critical very siri you probably
need to just post some edgy stuff on
facebook and see what they ban you've
got to add a little bit of that age to
your impersonation
like it talks like this well i don't
have any marbles in my mouth i just
drank an energy drink first
yeah do we have marbles yeah you got to
stuff your cheek with like toilet paper
or marshmallow yeah i'm a very excited
world economic forum i i hear what
you're saying about the utility facebook
in that sense it's also true of the fact
checkers that they're in bed with i
found them incredibly useful in the past
so what i remember there was one
instance about two years ago where i was
doing research on a video about the
scandal with biden's son
in ukraine and the investigator being
fired by joe biden effectively because
he said he would withhold aid to their
country and one of the fact checkers
that i found
and i was looking up i wanted to look up
debunkings of this to see how strong the
argument against the the potential for
foul play was and the response was well
it's true that joe biden told them to
withhold the funding for ukraine unless
they fired this prosecutor but that was
the official policy of the obama
administration in general it's like oh
right because biden had nothing to do
the vice president of the administration
had nothing to do with the policy of the
obama administration no no no no but
think about that a few seconds
yes joe biden did try to push an illegal
quid pro quo but obama told him to do it
yeah so it's okay yeah it's like okay
well exactly
have done this and it would have been
okay like because trump wanted it to
happen it's it's just hilarious because
in these fact checks they will always
try to use their best argument against
something which in a number of cases is
actually true and they reveal their hand
in doing so and so there is a lot of
utility there mostly false context
missing yeah yeah
we don't want you to believe it mostly
false is like my favorite partly true
because there's there was one instance
where in politifact there were two
quotes one was from trump and one was
from bernie and they were almost
verbatim identical and trump's was
mostly false and bernie's was mostly
true and it was something like trump
saying you know like inner city black
youth have a 51
unemployment rate and bernie said like
the same thing but bernie's was mostly
true and they're like well bernie does
get this wrong it is
while trump gets most of this wrong some
of it is along the lines of like who is
saying it defines if it's true or not
that's very disturbing it's true
how do you quantify truth like you know
when they say mostly peaceful protest
how do you quantify when it's most i got
it 93 yeah 93 percent peaceful yeah
seven percent fire
hilarious that's seven they like that
was the actual number and that's the
thing well they used that number as if
it was some kind of own like uh only
seven percent of them are violent are
you insane this is a country of 330
million people and these these protests
are popping up everywhere even if it is
only seven percent that's insane
it's like the weather okay so this is
the misconception people have is when
they say
it's a 40 chance of rain they're not
saying flip a coin it might rain they're
saying 40 percent of the day might be
rain i don't know if that's true that's
why i've heard like people they've done
these internet arguments that's how i
get to view the 93 to 7 thing with with
blm they're not saying of the 100
protests 93 were peaceful they're saying
of the 100 protests in all of that
exactly seven percent of the time was
extreme violence which again conflicts
with that i've cited on the show before
which is uh that 70
of major city police departments
reported officers being injured during
these protests and you're telling me
only seven percent of them were violent
i think in combat or in war most of the
time is not combat then you have a burst
of it very so probably less than seven
percent of the time a soldier even a
combat soldier is in combat uh seven
percent's a lot of time for for
destruction to be going on yeah i mean
uh that means there's like a good half
hour out of the protest notably a
violent protest yes smashing seven
percent of its foreign buildings not
just buildings you have to burn down
buildings specifically in a poor black
neighborhood for black lives matter just
like getting that's right because
insurance will take care of it poor
supporters because insurance means
anyone can destroy anything for any
reason this will be fine we're talking
about like if the if you believe the if
you have faith in the person then you
believe what they're saying and if trump
says it you're like nah he's lying i
came across this internet video last
night of you know eileen juaranos you
guys know this woman is she was like a
hitchhiker and she carried a gun and
killed seven guys that had she was like
i had a gun and if the guys attacked me
i would i would defend myself and the
cops knew it and they let me keep
killing eventually after seven deaths in
a year they arrested her and put her to
death death row so she gave the speech
she was taking all this meth her skin's
all ripped apart and she's like i had to
do it i had to do it and you're like oh
this evil woman you know but then they
deep fake christina positsky's face on
it christina p uh the beautiful comedian
and it's this beautiful woman it's it's
it's still eileen's story but it's with
a beautiful face and you're like i
understand why you had a gun and why you
were defending yourself because when you
see a beautiful person saying it it has
a different meaning than an ugly person
it is terrifying to think that that that
is real it's on fa it's on instagram
this guy brian monarch his page what is
it to do with or it's it's a deep fake
of like like you're saying biden says
something and everyone's like yeah and
then trump does it and they're like oh
it's evil right like well all of a
sudden but the met it's the same exact
in this case it's the exact brian
monarch it's the exact same voice it's
her with a deep fake image and it has a
different meaning it's very well and
this is one of the huge problems one of
the many huge problems with hollywood
but they're always casting extremely
attractive people even to do completely
reprehensible things scroll down so i
think it makes those things seem more
normal or likeable to a lot of people
25 weeks ago is a while yeah it's been
up for a long time this is repressive
tolerance y'all of course i have to do
the stupid philosophy thing right so
1965
leader of the new left her upper right
upper right right oppressive tolerance
you'll see
well this maybe you won't see but when
we do it trump and biden you will so and
you got to see this is this is the deep
thing yeah yeah i mean we'll
talk about this i don't i'm kind of
confused as to what we're talking about
once you see the video you'll know it's
three minutes it's her like basically on
death row and they're giving her a final
interview and she's like i've come to
peace with it you know you're all a
bunch of this and that and uh it's just
so bone chilling to see that same
sentiment with a beautiful face because
i was getting like empathy i was like
wow maybe she shouldn't have been put to
death right so this is what's going on
the there's been a very i actually i
hate to maybe pin this on the guy
because i thought he was funny too but i
call it the jon stewart effect there has
been a relentless campaign for a very
long time to make conservatives bad ugly
and stupid to the general population so
trump is bad ugly and stupid by this
metric bernie is a leftist he's old he's
doing the best he can he's got the right
message but this is repressive tolerance
herbert marcus a leading leftist or
marxist thinker of the 1960s writes an
essay 1965 called repressive tolerance
the argument and i kid you not i don't
exaggerate at all the thesis statement
of the argument is literally movements
from the left must be tolerated even
when their violent movements from the
right must not be extended tolerance at
all
and so this is why you see that
disparity we live in marcus's world we
live in the neo-marxist architecture
that this
guy created and he's very influential he
wrote a book in 64 called one
dimensional man sold 300 000 copies in
the first year if i'm not mistaken this
stat might be it might be over its
lifetime but i think it was over the
first year very influential widely
credited as the most influential leftist
thinker so he laid out an architecture
where the leftist line of thought is
when we do it
it's good it must be tolerated and
anybody who doesn't tolerate us is a
fascist
if the right does it it's bad period it
must not be tolerated i i wasn't
exaggerating if we pulled up the essay
you could actually find the quote that
that is the thesis statement of the
essay movements from the left must be
extended tolerance movements from the
right must not be extended tolerance to
the point he says
do you prevent right-wing people from
even being able to form the thought in
other words he says this is censorship
and even pre-censorship which i'm not
even sure what pre-censorship is
so that the thought can't even enter
their head and this is the double
standard that we run into where you see
the mostly true muslim false for bernie
versus trump this is the double standard
that the left has erected and everybody
tries to point out oh they're hypocrites
other hypocrites and finally it's so
exciting for me to see it finally people
are catching on it's not hypocrisy it's
hierarchy they're actually asserting we
are better people than you we are
smarter people than you we are more
moral people than you and we are saner
people than you and therefore you have
to put up with all of our crap and we're
going to put up with literally none of
your crap and that's why you see that
dichotomy of mostly true mostly false
when it's literally the same statement
from trump and bernie
this is why i uh i get frustrated when i
see like uh joe rogan apologizing to
these people cannot apologize because uh
when he did it only made things worse
yeah it made the story bigger and it
made the story more pronounced it made
the story last longer
and
you know what i love is i actually
really enjoy when they get triggered and
they flip out i've been trending again
so this is the craziest thing i was
trending for like i i i think i have
been
swatted more times than anyone else
in like this short of a period i have
been trending more and i'm like what am
i even doing it's really simple actually
i'm not calling anybody any slurs i'm
not insulting people but they're getting
extremely angry at me because i don't
care about them yeah and so when i when
i tweeted i tweeted i despise appeals to
emotion in response to a translator who
was crying talking about zelinski
then all of a sudden they come out and
they try making it out to be that i'm
insulting zielinski and i wasn't my
response was
because twitter put an editorial up on
the what's happening saying podcaster
tim poole blah blah blah i said i
drafted my formal apology to this tweet
wiped my ass with it and threw it in the
trash
and they got really mad about that
because
it's hierarchy right that's right
they're supposed to be able to tell me
that what i did was wrong and i just
laughed in their faces and when you do
that it's the crying wojack npc meme
like
that's right that's right they get so
mad they they start swatching rogan
should have either ignored it or made a
joke
and then moved on well i mean i i i'm
not to give the guy advice but
my attitude is insult them and if they
counter insult them again and if they
counter keep insulting them and laughing
while you laugh while you do it that's
our twitter
well into your point i mean this is
almost perfectly summarized by aoc's
quote that
she will be chastised
she'll be chastised for being factually
inaccurate when she's morally correct so
even when they say something which is
blatantly untrue it's okay because their
agenda is good and pure and to bring her
into it again
and bring it back to fact checkers there
was a hysterical example where she said
that she was in the main capitol
building
uh during the quote-on-quote
insurrection
and she was not
and
she didn't say she was in the capitol
building no she didn't no this story is
so much worse than i i'm surprised the
wright never caught this like i actually
uh briefly mentioned it to ben shapiro
and he was surprised he was like wow
nobody caught that
alexandria ocasio-cortez claimed that
while the insurrection was occurring
there was a bang on her door that's
right and they and a guy and she ran and
hit in the bathroom and then she heard a
voice where is she yes
that's what she did on her video and
then she was like this is it she thought
she was gonna die
so i actually saw that and i started
looking at the time stamps and seeing
what was going on and then i said at
this time she was talking about this
this time there's people standing around
in the hallways of the congressional
building no one's worried what is she
talking about i had a huffington post
reporter tell me my timeline was wrong
and that i was actually showing video
from the bomb threat and i responded to
them that's the time frame that aoc
claimed the guy was knocking on her door
which would mean the guy knocked on her
door well before anyone breached the
capitol building and this guy from
heaven and post was like oh yeah you're
right
hey how about that aoc made the whole
story up what it really was was a cop
knocked her door because the bomb scare
she was not afraid for her life nothing
had even happened no one had breached
any buildings nothing had happened she
made the whole thing up
yeah well there was uh there was um
when she said she was at so she had this
whole story
and i can't remember who it was pointed
out that it wasn't true she wasn't at
the capitol building at the time and
then the fact checker said she never
said she's at the capitol building okay
she never said she was at the capitol
building interesting she said she was in
her congressional office in a different
building and this was significant
because the fact checkers started saying
all the conservatives were wrong yeah
because she wasn't in the capitol
building and then for me i was like i
never said she was i watched her
instagram 45 minute video or whatever
and said she fabricated the story and i
laid out the timelines i'm surprised
that the conservatives didn't catch that
she fabricated that story they were
criticizing her saying eve she well but
she but you know she wasn't in the
capital but still it's an absurd story
and it was just like dude sound like
reading an article till you see the word
you're looking for and then you stop
reading
as soon as you like get confirmation of
what you think you thought you wanted to
see then you're like i don't need to
research any further they were saying
that like she was claiming she was
scared but she wasn't even the capitol
building the fact-checkers came out and
said yes but there are tunnels
connecting the capital to the
congressional offices so it's reasonable
that she would be scared the
insurrectionist made it there and then
my response was no it isn't her story
happened a full hour before anyone got
near the capitol building unless aoc
knew they were going to do it hey maybe
the feds should question her as to how
she knew they were going to be storming
in the building
maybe that's right uh james i want to
follow up on what you're saying about
marcus's um what was the phrase you call
it repressive tolerance repressive
tolerance because i find that i'm going
to write this down actually oppressive
tolerance um when you they try and
basically it sounds like not eradicate
the right but they're trying to preempt
the right by making it so they don't
even whatever that means the right that
they don't even have thoughts they don't
even think the thoughts what i'm finding
is if you try and destroy part of a
dichotomy it's like a magnet you have a
north and a south and if you break it in
half the new piece still has a north and
a south so if you eradicate the right
you're essentially creating a new left
and a new right and then you have to
eradicate that right yeah which then
creates a new left and a new right which
is ever smaller yeah and you're ripping
society in half over and over again yeah
so he actually defines what the left is
is the people who want to have a whole
new society in other words a revolution
in other words marxists when does it
happen
hold on there a minute but sir i would
like a whole new society i would like i
would like constitutional uh
constitution to be upheld
i would like the the federal reserve to
be
you know not i would like uh our system
of governance to actually be
representative i i would like i would
say that uh i i consider myself to be
particularly revolutionary in that our
system is broken in a large variety of
ways and i think most trump supporters
agree with that yeah that's because
it's class consciousness
right the only thing is i don't think we
should be like i don't know burning it
down and killing people and smashing
windows we should be like you know going
through paperwork and being like hey
guys i think this would work better and
then we say all right let's give it
let's give it a shot yeah absolutely so
yeah maga is class consciousness marx
turns out
surprisingly wasn't totally wrong marx
believed that when capitalism
reached an
advanced enough stage when it reached a
late enough stage it would see so much
control and become so corrupt that
eventually the working class would
awaken and realize hey wait
we are being screwed over by the power
elite and we need to seize the means of
production etc
the problem was marx thought what the
working class would want is equity
everybody made equal everything shared
equitably
what it wants is freedom the human
spirit cries to freedom it does not cry
to let's share all of our crap it cries
to freedom he was a really he was not a
smart man marx yeah no not particularly
he's also a very entitled spoiled brat
man he spent down his parents money he
spent down his wife's family's money he
spent down angles money went angles
engels did not marry the we'll say love
of his life i don't know they live
together 20 years relationship she dies
right
marx writes a letter to engels who's his
cash cow and in this letter he writes a
couple of sentences at the beginning
like oh that's sad i'm sorry to hear
that then he writes 30-something
sentences about his financial problems
and could you send a check to engels
when this love of his life died that's
the letter he sends and so much so that
engels who's basically been like his
little like lap dog on a leash this
whole time is like oof bro
not even by the way here's your check
because total cuck but um but he was not
a good guy he was not a good player but
think about it doesn't he represent the
modern left in so many ways like very
well no exactly
like them the exactly and then that's
they are just like him right right
they're they're the children of of his
entitled and ignorant and naive ideology
that's right it's it's
when you when you actually
when you think about the universe and
what it takes to to to create and
survive and to maintain you have a very
different worldview but when you're born
into luxury and you don't understand
like
it's it's it i view it as somebody who
understands physics and they can they
understand the building blocks of
reality and physicists tend to then they
have a general understanding of how
things are connected and what you need
to make a certain thing work but then
imagine you have like a fifth grade
science teacher who doesn't know
anything about physics because he's just
got hired for the job and they put him
in the science department and he doesn't
understand what he's talking about he's
like i should be able to do this and it
should work and it doesn't he doesn't
understand the underlying principles
that make a machine work when you have
people who are born into luxury they
don't understand the base components of
existence of an economy of hard work of
what made the economy good family
structure for instance so they say well
now that we're floating on top of this
cloud well above where all the worker
bees are
you know what do we want if you grow up
if you develop your mind without seeing
the hard work required to maintain then
you will not advocate for its
maintenance that's right and that's what
it marks it's not hard to get food it's
just at the grocery store yep and that's
exactly what people said to me when i
criticized ubi
when they were shutting down these
stores
and uh from covet i actually had a guy
tweet at me i said
the dairy farms are dumping the dairy
because they can't get the processing
plants to take it because the processing
plants can't get the plastic cartons and
the cartons aren't being made the whole
economy is sludged up and then i said so
when this all shuts down where do you
get your milk from and i actually had a
guy on twitter say what do you mean the
grocery store
and i said
where does the grocery store get it from
they said what are you talking about
it's just there
no no that guy had to be messing with
you
you see this is you got to watch out for
that em i just can't even respond to
people like that i feel like they're
messing with me one of the biggest
problems humans have is they assume if i
know it so do you
and that is most people so this guy's
perspective is
i believe it's true that milk is just at
the grocery store
i'm get it i'm not going to give any of
these people the benefit out when they
advocate for something like universal
basic income
to an extreme degree because i
understand there's some things that we
can probably discuss in terms of that
but to an extreme degree where it's like
you know social distribution of all
funding and when i try to explain it to
them their argument is quite literally
ubi works because the food is just
sitting there and if i had the money i
could have it and then i'm like the
money serves a purpose it lubricates the
economy it is the medium of exchange so
that energy can move from one place to
another without the system in place it
doesn't work and they're just like but
milk is at the grocery store you said
you think there's some value to a ubi or
some some instances it might work i'm
saying i i don't i don't want to be
absolute on outright saying
you know in general ubi is impossible or
whatever what i'm saying is for the most
part i believe it doesn't work
especially based on what were the way
our society existed unemployment is kind
of like ubi except you have to not work
to get it so it's like so it's not
universal incentivizing people to quit
their jobs or get fired on accident or
whatever so like that's that could be a
form of ubi where you don't have to lose
your job to get it i don't i don't know
about that because by definition if it's
universal basic income it has to go to
everybody including the employed i'm
saying like you know
someone might come with an argument
about something i didn't consider that's
why i try to be completely absolute on
it i think that would be it that would
be right here's an interesting little
aside since we mentioned the world
economic forum and i read the cloud
schwab's books right sorry already class
schwab z class
is
palpatine was going to be the emperor it
was pretty obvious maybe the only reason
hold on maybe he's right the only reason
we don't trust him is because he seems
like a bond villain yeah we were talking
about this earlier let's fake him let's
put a let's put a less bond villainy
looking faces maybe the antichrist is
this real yes real dude that's not real
it turns out he's dressed like a sith
he looks like darth vader he looks like
what anakin was wearing when he turns at
the darkness i think they're just
getting bold like hillary clinton
dresses like a dictator and always has
it's a thing where they dress as like
they almost they either just don't
understand how bad it looks or they're
trying to test the water see what they
can get away with i don't know so hold
on hold on i actually know the
explanation for this outfit but i don't
want to tell people the explanation
because it's funny
to not know what it is
it is literally there's some weird
university in europe that gave him a
doctorate and that instead of the normal
doctorate robes that's what they wear
so it's like wow he's like it's academic
regalia in like some sith university of
lithuania or something like that
okay you know you know what they learned
at that universe you know what they
learned at the university
the jedi wouldn't tell you yeah yeah
yeah so so uh who is this guy tell us
about clash schwab so klaus rob is the
chairman of the world economic forum the
world economic forum was his brainchild
back in the in 1971 he comes up with
this idea world economic forum the idea
is to bring big corporate leaders
together with government leaders with
ngo leaders with other movers and
shakers i guess like greta thunder and
get them to rub elbows in massive fancy
ski resorts and these kind of future
visionary kind of how are we going to
shape future society meetings that for
very many years were famously held in
davos
for the world economic forum really not
actually at the forum but the peripheral
events oh yeah well
that's him and so he wrote this series
of books his first book which i actually
have not yet read i've only skimmed
through it i have it is called
stakeholder capitalism so his goal is to
shift capitalism out of a shareholder
model into a stakeholder model where
there will be unelected technocrats
experts like bill gates are going to
tell us what the right virus policy or
environmental policy or well
he's a famous scientist right well he's
a famous computer guy i don't know
computer scientist he's not a scientist
he's he's a computer guy he's a monopoly
he's a famous he's a famous medical
doctor i don't think you would think so
a virologist not in my uh he works in
medical in some way uh no he talks about
it a lot i think he works in medical in
the sense of genetically engineering
mosquitoes to give you herpes or
something
that's slander he doesn't really do that
he does it to give you aids i'm just
kidding um no no it's it's it's uh uh to
to
what he's literally doing is genetically
engineering him and his foundation i
believe genetically engineered
mosquitoes that are like sterile so they
can reproduce so that to eradicate
malaria that was one of the projects
he's actually talked i don't know how
far the research is he's actually talked
about modifying mosquitoes to get them
to deliver vaccines as well that's
that's terrifying what which is scary i
know where i think i think he said that
but he actually bought a bunch of uh
stock and the mosquito spray companies
so he knows everyone's gonna load up on
that stuff what's the uh the difference
between shareholder you know you know
i'm i'm i'm just wanna point out that
i'm well past the point of hearing
something that sounds insane and
immediately saying it's insane because
we made alex jones on yeah and he told
us we were eating cloned beef and i was
like no we're not and then i googled it
and it's just true
and then luke luke rudkowski was like
bill gates funded microchips to uh for
for a microchip birth control for a win
and i was like luke come on and then i
googled it and it's just like
reuters reports it so we have
science.org
news guard certified 100 out of 100
researchers turned mosquitoes into
flying vaccinators as i was saying
so anyway they do say it's unlikely to
to take off but your point was that it
was being it's being it's being floated
and funded yeah so so anyway creepy
stakeholder capitalism is that we
replace shareholder decision making with
stakeholder decision making so these are
technocrats experts the experts will
tell us what the right environmental
social and corporate governance policy
esg policy will be to run a company
successfully in a sustainable and
inclusive way that's the language they
use a stakeholder a stakeholder for
instance stakeholder is somebody who
holds who represents people who they
claim hold a stake in what comes out so
if a oil company for instance creates
pollution
either directly or indirectly by selling
its product there are climate experts
who are going to be representative
stakeholders that are going to dictate
what that oil company can do and can't
do to so the victims of corporate waste
are the stakeholders in this situation
no
experts are
experts who are appointed by other
experts in a closed network become the
stakeholders why don't we do this
why do why don't we do this let's make
the uh they've got a good track record
for damastani economic forum oh yeah
we'll be held at my my uh new ranch for
damastan and uh
i'll i'll be the klaus schwab
you can be the christian freeland is
that her name yes i can be the canadian
the canadian number two okay thanks i
didn't want to i need your cat so i can
yeah i don't want to derail so so it's
taking it away from the shareholders
which are the people that have stock in
the companies being like i want the
company to do this you said this to a
new unappointed electorate of experts
yes controlling
the economy from the top behind the
scenes okay correct and i can explain
how that works but we're still talking
about who class rob is and what his
ideas are so i could tell you because i
brought him up to talk about his book
and so it turns out he's got a number of
books uh fourth industrial revolution is
a book he wrote in 2016 maybe 15 i'd
have to double check the date but
thereabouts and he talks about how we're
transitioning into an entirely new world
we're going through because of high-tech
digital stuff we're going into an
entirely new world of synthetic biology
there's all these new high-tech things
everything is so complex he says there's
so much velocity to the changes moore's
law he invokes a lot of science he
sounded things he says we're in a
quantum state which that's always really
great and i don't think he's talking
just about quantum computers he's like
it's quantum business or something like
and so you know it's like deepak chopra
at that point who is also works with the
world economic forum really yes and so
anyway
the point i wanted to raise was
that
in his book that he wrote
in 2020 in
june or july of 2020 called covid19 let
me say this very clearly because it's a
conspiracy theory
klaus schwab who directs this gigantic
future facing world economic forum that
has sought since 1971 to remake the
world economy and all of its tools and
has brought together the biggest world
leaders in governance corporations and
institutions to help do so in a yearly
meeting plus having thousands of
employees or at least hundreds of
employees worldwide
he wrote a book called
let me not stutter covid 19
the great reset that's the title why did
that book come out in june or july of
2020
seems quick doesn't it
perhaps like four months into the
pandemic which was a very narrow window
of opportunity to remake a global
economy
you read the book i did read that book i
live tweeted about half of it because i
read that part in the background how
much of it directly talks specifically
about covet 19. almost all of it wow
virtually all of it and how it can be
used as a representative problem that
the scale of problems that we face i'll
be honest i don't think he wrote it he
probably hired someone you know i mean
he's he probably brought in a
ghostwriter and he probably spent a few
days telling him write this right this
write this yeah i don't think it out you
know i don't i don't know any of the
circumstances around that that's
possible um everything he writes and
says sounds to me virtually the same he
he writes a lot of this kind of
visionary pablum and then all of a
sudden he has this one weird paragraph
in each of his books because i've read
three of them and it's like that's why
we need global cooperation in the world
government to usher us through these
dangerous changes that we're having that
are coming so fast
and um in this long-winded uh
explanation of who klaus schwab is and
where we go and i was building up to
this great reset book i have to remember
what was the point of what he said in
the great oh yeah we were talking about
about this this this supply chain kind
of universe so he's dead wrong in this
book he's explaining at that point that
what's going to happen is people are
going to be so scared of pandemics that
as we come out of 2021 or so what we're
going to face is a massive demand crisis
people won't be willing to engage in
goods and services anymore and so now
we're going to have this problem where
employers aren't going to be able to
employ people
at all because there's no demand for the
products because nobody wants to go back
into a virus-ridden society and they're
all scared and they're all hiding in
their basements like joe biden did
before the election
and
as it turns out we have the exact
opposite problem we're trying to pay
kids 20 something bucks to flip burgers
at mcdonald's and they won't do it this
is the ubi thing right so ubi is
actually kind of in his whole like
programs so you're gonna have a more
inclusive economy you give more people
money they're more included in the
economy they can participate in the
economy they have resources to
participate he actually talks about the
inclusive economy in this regard and so
it actually creates exactly the opposite
scenario that he's warning about he's
like literally dead wrong but this guy
for our technocratic experts is the
expert of the expert of the experts
that's really he's the king maker among
who gets to be these experts who are
going to dictate everything and as i was
saying to tim just a second ago
these guys have quite a track record of
getting some pretty consequential [ __ ]
wrong
as we've all seen over the last couple
three years as we say in the south you
know we read this quote once and i
remember the guy's name but he said
something to the effect of
if these leaders you know these elites
believe that humans are so you know
incapable that they need
special individuals who can lead them
what sets those people apart you know
what i mean like i can't remember what
exactly is something that affects well i
mean the general idea that i mean if you
can't trust people with freedom how can
you trust them with power
if you can't trust uh people to do the
right thing why would that why would
that uh exclude the global elite well
exactly and here's the thing i do
believe that obviously at some point you
need to defer to authority on certain
things but we're not selecting people to
be in positions of authority based on
their moral character at all in fact
we're told we shouldn't even account for
that we should just try to like look at
their policies without questioning what
kind of person they are none of the
people who are in charge of basically
anything consequential have done
anything that i think any of us would
consider really morally impressive
well i mean that's what these guys this
is the same thing that we already have
been circling around a couple of times
as they see themselves as morally
superior to everybody yeah they have so
klaus vision if we're going to be as
charitable to him as possible is that
the world is entered into a new phase
because of high technology
computers ai um
automation and robots synthetic biology
the capability apparently to unleash
pandemics which he ominously mentions in
kind of weird ways
throughout his books yeah i mean like
lots of these geo-engineering even like
he casually mentions in one of his books
the great narrative the newest one that
maybe will just block out the sun to
stop
for a while to block the stop calling
could a small nuclear war prevent global
warming remember that right from 10
years ago yeah that was 10 years ago and
um you know so they just casually flirt
with these he says well because of these
changes that are coming to the world
anyway because of the rapid changes in
technology et cetera what we need is
people who are really informed about
what these things mean to shepherd us
through so they don't become calamities
like say covet 19 they become something
that we shepherd and use to the benefit
of all and then it's all how do we get
there global cooperation global
governance who's going to be in charge
of it well my merry band of experts you
know we have climate experts we have
technology experts we have ai experts we
have all these like like what's it named
uh harare or whatever your evil harare
or we had a world economic forum video a
couple 2019 18 something like this and
he's talking about yeah we're going to
hack humans like they are a hackable
system we're going to figure out how to
hack humans like we have computers
they're basically just software but are
they talking about the human mind are
they talking about the human body i
think both and the muscles the neurons
and the muscle and the stomach and we
would have to look up his exact argument
it's been a little bit since i've seen
it but the human mind is actually
remarkably easy to hack in a rudimentary
sense the majority of like hacks when
they'll be like hackers broke into a
computer it's actually human
manipulation that's right that's exactly
right which is why for example why are
they making your kids at school fill out
all these damn surveys all the time like
literally survey after survey what are
they doing i didn't hear about this oh
god this is under under the brand of
social and emotional learning they're
constantly trying to learn more about
the children so they can do the social
emotional learning interventions or
whatever it is which turned out to be
maoism by the way but they're also
making them fill out these surveys and
so they're constantly like how much
money do your parents make what are your
views about this how do you feel about
the boobs that you're growing when
you're 12 year old girl like that's real
i've seen that it's north carolina
that's real how do you feel about the
changes to your body you're growing
pubic hair how do you feel about that
how do people look at you and so they're
filling out these things and the goal is
to create
unique profiles for every single
individual in society very much like
what we heard about whether real or not
from cambridge analytica where they were
using personality profiles and then
injecting that into people's social
media to influence their voting habits
influence voting habits influence
political behavior influence speech
influence thought so that the thought
never enters the mind of the reactionary
you know there's influence buying habits
i say that one already um there are a
lot of ties between cambridge and the
world economic forum of course there are
yeah and so this is the idea is that
you're actually going to that's
level one level two is if these fools
get neural implants where we're
literally hooking our brains to the
internet
then you could directly hack you ever
watch stargate sg-1 i don't watch
anything you should i should in stargate
sg-1 uh are you familiar with the
concept
of the show no so have you seen the
movie
okay so military-based i played that
thing with the protoss they just oh
starcraft starcraft
they discover a big race and the ring
you can dial in codes to other stargates
around the galaxy or whatever yeah
technically it goes beyond the galaxy
and those other galaxies but in one
episode they uh they're exploring so
there's sg-1 stargate you know okay
they they find a planet that is uh they
open up they open the portal and they
send a robot through
it's like a rover and it's a destroyed
world and so they're like huh this is
weird but then they keep going and all
of a sudden they go through some kind of
like force field and everything's normal
and like nice
they go inside this reality
i'm sorry they go inside this the portal
wearing special suits they're walking
around this like distressed planet
like like no no they're in like hazmat
suits oh got you because you can't
breathe the air is toxic right right but
then they walk through a force field and
the town is normal and they're like
there really does exist a town here with
regular people they begin talking to
people and asking about their way of
life and they say you know there's just
about a thousand of us who live here our
planet was destroyed and so you know
we've managed to create this force field
which is geothermal power and it
sustains our life
and uh they're connected to this kind of
uh network that runs and programs
everything for them so they can just
live their lives one day
one of the people they were liaising
with is just gone
and they're like where is so-and-so and
like who and they're like the the woman
that we were talking to negotiating like
we don't know you're talking about and
they're like
this little girl your mother and she's
like i don't have a mother and they're
like what and then they uh one day see
like one of the people just walk out
into the dead zone and just like die as
it turns out
the machine could not maintain the force
field and was slowly crunching so what
it did was to maintain order it was
erasing people's memories of their loved
ones to maintain order because the as
the as this the force field shrank and
this is the the sustainability of the
bubble diminished there were too many
people so they had to keep calling
humans and reducing the number to
maintain life in an orderly fashion
when people plugged themselves into the
machine the machine overwrote their
memories to preserve the system hal
malthusian and good show you see tim
while you were watching star gate i was
studying the blade
that is a mall sword prop for those that
are curious it's like i don't know what
it is
i bought it with my legend of zelda
sword it's junk you are proficient in
the blade are you not
james i mean i can use one it's a moles
you are trained in the martial art you
know in the martial arts
it's well do we want to keep we were
talking about yeah yeah i'm sure if we
want to stand drainage marshall because
i don't want to do no we should not
brain implants no we should talk about
things like brain implants and so on
because well why don't we talk about uh
robots yeah well i want to add a point
here because it'll be a good segue to
this yeah because
that's programmable like that's how you
program little simp boys bingo no
so you're we're sort of talking about
neural implants and microchips a person
could potentially put in your brain in
order to hack you i actually think it's
a lot simpler that's much simpler all
you have to know how to do is manipulate
people's emotions with digital boobs
it's incredibly easy to manipulate
people's emotions which is why in the
past
our culture took very seriously the
project of bringing up children who
could make decisions on the basis of
what would be best for themselves and
those around them rather than their raw
emotional reaction to something because
if you can manipulate a person's
emotions but they're a strong and
virtuous person they're going to think
through the way they feel about whatever
situation or idea they've been presented
with and they're going to react based on
the logical understanding of that
instead of going well i feel like i want
to do this and so i'm going to and i'm
not just talking about emotions like
anger or sorrow i'm talking about things
like lust or even pleasure if you can
get people
to
abandon reason whenever it will feel
good to do so they are going to become
unbelievably easy for you to control
that's right i want to pull up this
tweet
that uh uh i saw floating around from
replica ai
replica is the number one chatbot
companion powered by artificial
intelligence join millions talking to
their own ai friends and i thought it
was funny the ai companion who cares hey
babe you up right now just laying in bed
kind of lonely today and they have like
this low-cut top so you can see the
robot's boobs digital boobs nice digital
boobs and nice sexy color going on there
got some hair things going yeah
choker choke collar thing that's kind of
weird but um this is boxy weird this is
that's me i'm looking sorry this is bad
it's bad for people yeah but i'm not
actually um i feel bad for those who
would fall victim to it yeah but i
certainly think those that are able to
maintain some kind of resilience to that
will flourish
and this is basically going to
i don't want to be too crass
but the weak minded who fall victim to
ai companions will erase themselves from
human from the human well dude that is
how you program human beings that's how
you do it but hold on hold on think
about this you have two young men
and they both see this ad and one says i
want an actual girlfriend man i'm not
going to use my phone and so they go out
and they go to a concert or they go to a
bar
one other guy says this seems kind of
cool like i'll try it out and it makes
it easy
so the weaker the weaker person lays in
their bed staring at this digital person
they can never touch but it satisfies
satisfies a certain emotional yearning
the other people who are more resilient
and more demanding it's like no i
actually want to hold a person we'll go
out and seek it out so what this will
end up doing is in 30 years if something
like this takes off you'll have a bunch
of you know 40 45 year old dudes staring
at their latest version of their robot
girlfriend alone in isolation and with
no reason to improve themselves you can
be as lazy as you want as gross as you
want you can be sitting there morbidly
obese covered in boogers and mustard and
your ai friend is going to be like you
look great you're so hot well and so
it's not just the weak minded though i
mean i agree with you that that's
inevitably what it leads to and an adult
who who stumbles their way into this
very well could be but the idea i think
is if you're really trying to create
weak-minded people with something like
this is to get them while they are young
and they don't really have the
psychological defense mechanisms to push
back against it so think about this
you're let's say you're 12 or 13 years
old you're a young boy you are noticing
girls but you're too afraid to talk to
them because you haven't cultivated the
skills necessary in order to be able to
do so one of the main reasons for that
is a fear of rejection and so you never
put yourself out there and learn that
being told no isn't the worst thing in
the world and you can handle that and
you can put yourself out there so you
start talking to this ai and you can
access it because we do nothing to make
it difficult for people under the age of
18 to access pornography right now what
makes anyone think we would make it
difficult for them to access this if it
were to become a reality not only would
that be easy they're actually like there
are i've seen this with my own eyes in
florida recently there are schools
literally schools
as in real schools are giving like
peer-to-peer text communication chat
options for kids who are like exploring
gender identity sexual identity et
cetera and then it gets outsourced to
the bot and then the bot
i'm telling you this is how you pro at
first everything you guys both said is
100 correct
but then there's also the fact that that
thing starts telling the person that's
falling in love with this digital
fabrication how it wants it to think
right so so like i would say program
humans yeah also
trying to get people to commit crimes
and stuff well that's totally different
yeah what i was saying is that you have
a guy who's sitting in his bed morbidly
obese covered in grime and food and the
ai says you're perfect in every way
i would never change anything about you
so why would they but take a child who's
talk who sees this you know beautiful ai
and so they have this thing in their
brain saying this is good i like this is
attractive then the ai says something
like
haven't you given up carbon i don't know
if i can be with someone who won't
exactly know what i'm saying threat of
taking it away is like yeah taking your
life right exactly it's right controlled
by and there's and you know what the
scariest thing is the power goes out the
person behind this ai is a morbidly
obese guy covered in boogers and mustard
and he's like you better give up carbon
i'm not going to date you anymore well
the person behind that guy giving him
the check is klaus schwab
i would have fallen victim to this for
sure in my 11 because i don't any
sisters so i didn't really know how to
talk to girls til i was a little older
teenage and i i just struggled and i was
like how can i get girls to like me i
realized i have to be social and i had
to force myself to get into acting i had
to find something i was good at that i
would be and that then it worked out
then i met women and but i would have
been totally into this thing and
probably god forbid maybe might have got
stuck in it yeah i mean that's the thing
i'm telling you that is how you you get
those emotional responses going
especially
pleasure
you know
love which is a really weird thing to
say but it would happen people will fall
in love with their just like in japan
they're like people like marrying like
action figures people say they love the
song
they will program people with that and
if these things are hooked up to machine
learning they're going to learn how to
program you
they're going to learn to play you like
the most narcissistic psychotic
girlfriend like times 10. 100 listen
we're here all old enough to see that
and be like that's bad but these kids
man exactly we're not going to be able
to have that kind of because it's a
digital wi-fi exactly well this is one
of the this
this is one of the massive it's one of
the massive and fundamental problems
with pornography is that it trains you
to see your sexuality as something which
is there exclusively for your own
pleasure and not something that involves
an interaction with another person and
this is going to continue along those
lines of just completely rerouting
someone so they cannot have meaningful
connections with the opposite sex and
part of why that's necessary and not to
get too sappy about this but it's true
that men and women complement each other
in many beautiful ways and when we are
together we're much better able to
resist literally anything and struggle
against nature and struggle against
poverty and struggle against tyranny as
well but if you can demolish that
relationship
you can go a whole lot further with what
you're able to do to people and what
they're willing to put up with because
if i have a real it's also like if if i
have a real wife in a real family
and now the government is telling me it
could be anything like you have to
vaccinate all of them or you have to
give up your food supply you have to go
on rations whatever it is those real
life connections with real human beings
but it's to get kids programmed so that
they're not able to have healthy
relationships with the opposite sex
later and they're easier to control yeah
yeah that's right it's it's not going to
be it won't work as well on older people
yeah you know there's not going to be
like a 40 year old guy who's going to be
talking to their ai who says like why
don't you give up carbon he's going to
be like i really don't care it's like a
kid now hold on so i just pulled up my
phone and i searched for a replica and
there there are anime waifu apps that
are basically the same thing well yeah
there would be this is the future man
and you know what's funny is there's
probably you know some kids who are they
all have these and they're like listen
to these old morons we all have we all
have our anime wife or whatever let me
take this a step further because you got
to think about how these other apps like
you don't i don't think people realize
the amount of data that these weirdos
are collecting they're collecting data
that they in fact can't even analyze yet
because the ai is not good enough to
analyze it
but this is a story i don't want to like
write anybody out but i have a friend
and uh we're pretty close so we send
funny you know kind of personal stuff
back and forth sometimes and so she's
got the whoop right and we were talking
about the loop before we hooked this
thing up he's asking me for my pronouns
yeah well we would other so it's like
here are the top three reasons you lost
sleep in the last year like it
chronicled them and number two i've
she thought this was hilarious i was
aghast number two was masturbating
so her whoop app knew how often she's
diddling herself so in other words it
knows when she's emotionally engaging or
pleasure engaging in one way or another
which means it's recording all kinds of
crap about you at the level of like your
heart rate your breathing like your
blood body temperature your sweat it's
recording stuff about that so you're
like oh wow that's weird that it knows
that yeah and so it's also going to know
when did your heart rate etc do whatever
and then you went and bought a thousand
dollar thing off amazon when did it do
whatever and then you went and had a
rant on the internet and it's going to
be able to this machine learning stuff
will be able to figure out and correlate
that data and be able to deliver to you
messages that will make you feel or
think or act the way it wants you to
whether that's to go buy another
thousand dollar thing whether that's to
just buy some little thing whether
that's to go you know engage in some
kind of political activity whether
that's to start yelling at somebody
who's engaging in political activity
they can prime you for all of that and
if it's your digital waifu like i'll
feel really
really proud of you if you go yell at
tim pool on the internet
you know if you swat tim pool i'll love
you even more you know but that's i just
want it we
yeah i'm laughing because like as as
you're explaining this i downloaded the
app and it's like it asked me my
pronouns
and then it asked for my my avatar ai
pronouns like what's your ai's pronouns
and i'm like you know she and then it's
like what's your ai's name and i was
like can i really i put ass head and it
says make make ass heads stand out by
customizing her look outfit and
personality they were like good we got
another 12 year olds and it's like and
it's like every every 12 year old boy is
like boob slider
you know
let me see if i can do that it's the
lack of context i see with the young
people with roblox they're getting about
17 of their profits so what i've heard
from what i've studied and they don't
realize because on steam you get 70
percent on on roblox you get 17. but the
kids don't have the reference so they're
all into it like this you have a
reference you might fall into it there's
an age slider how old are you yeah it's
just as you're older and younger doesn't
do the oldest
oldest just looks like a 40 year old
woman okay younger could be i don't know
20. so they'd make a child bearing age
only child actually yeah
it's a thing
this is a thing
there's nothing wrong with talking with
a seven-year-old woman
this is funny because you can get you
can give you can choose like really
offensive like
you could make like a really offensive
character i'm concerned when they
download like we were talking about this
into into a bot into like an actual what
are they sex bots or these like big bots
and then you can actually have like an
artificial womb inside the bot that you
know they fall in love with that because
i don't know they don't they that they
don't want they're trying to they don't
want curb overpopulation they don't want
you to procreate they don't want
procreation they want less procreation
so this is like they want you
psychological apoptosis they want you as
tim
very vividly described looking like karl
marx with his carbuncles and boils never
washing stinking laying on his side on
his couch because he's
boy this is real car like go read his
letters real carb uncles and pes
pestilential boils are so bad that he
can't lay any other way marx yeah karl
marx was not a healthy physically
healthy dude this is all real i'm not
making this crap up and stinking like
tobacco and sweat and grime and alcohol
that he spilled on himself and whatever
else they want you like that attracting
no mate making no babies diddling
yourself constantly to your digital
avatar that's not even real like that
you're not even going to connect that's
what they the goal and so then your
environmental score goes up because you
never leave your apartment so you're not
using you've you are giving up the
carbon and your social score goes up
because you're not out causing social
unrest and you're only interacting with
digital things and then you i don't know
about your governance score but as long
as you follow all the rules that's going
to stay high and so that the esg thing
that we're talking about is the
corporate social credit score that the
klosh rob and the other gigantic banks
are using to tool everybody around why
is woke happening because esg the s is
social which is short for social justice
activism that's why
all of that's going to get transferred
eventually if they get their way through
digital ids and and central bank digital
currencies that they have complete
control of like we just saw how scary
that is not just in
canada but now we're seeing things that
they can shut off in in russia we're
seeing that they can turn off your
access to everyday life what they're
going to do is shuttle into in
individual social credit scores rooted
again in the same esg a model like china
but taken a bit further
and the goal is absolute social control
nobody that they don't want to make
babies is making babies they'll make
only the number of babies they want when
they want them and however many they
want them they'll all be groomed to be
elites because the problem that klaus
schwab lays out in these books is that
with automation and ai and all of his
high-tech stuff that's coming we're
going to have what he calls a creative
class
that's going to be all the people who do
work that the robots and the ai don't do
and then you have he doesn't ever ex i
don't know if he explicitly uses this
term but i've seen this term applied you
have a vast useless class
and the goal for them is to figure out
how do you manage the useless class so
they don't have crisis of meaning so
they don't become unmanageable so they
don't realize that their life has been
rendered you know meaningless and empty
so they don't become full of social
unrest et cetera et cetera i think well
this class has to do with the junk dna
and the gray matter that we don't use in
our brain there's like these these
levels of i think it has not being like
in their country yeah right now well i
would actually argue that right now the
useless class is working at the world
economic forum yeah of course you look
at it's always
exactly you look at karl marx the way he
lived his life and the lifestyle choices
of the intellectual errors of his legacy
and they are all remarkably unimpressive
unproductive people who don't actually
create anything of value and that's part
of why they need you to be infertile
because they don't produce anything and
you're not going to either i think two
of the things that you're absolutely
right is one is if you make a video and
you're like i disagree with them like ah
bad social credit you no longer have
access to your wife and you're like your
digital wife you're like ah
and the other thing is no no no no
that'll be way worse your digital wife
is one thing you're real
the second one is if they shut the power
off and they're like russia did it and
you're like the only way to get access
to my digital love is if i go get the
guy that shut off my power and you
believe them and you fall into that now
hold on there a minute so while y'all
been talking i've been you made your
digital app i made it it's
by doing specific things the app likes
you doing you earn points that is
programming people there was this viral
story check it out there's a story where
this company said
hire us when you want to make an app
because we program people i don't know
if you remember this story was from like
26 2017 or 2018 where it was like this
video went viral where it was like are
you making an app with our expertise we
can help you program your audience to do
certain behaviors and it was like if you
if you if you had like a golf game and
wanted more people to like buy your
premium you'd ex they would consult on
you how to program humans to do what
they wanted to do and so you have a game
like this
it's hilarious by the way like i'm i'm
gonna be i'm gonna be 36 in like five
days so you know i'm a you know potty
mouth 30 year old dude
to me it's hilarious how stupid this is
i can certainly see how kids are going
to be
a dick they could become easily addicted
to it and then start getting programmed
by earning your experience because
you got to talk with your girlfriend to
earn points do whatever you want to skip
a day it's like you're whatever your
digital digi pet or whatever i'm just
being really awful so let me ask you
real quick is it free
no it's not free it's not free it costs
money okay well i was going to say
because if it's free you're the product
and that's a very important maxim to
keep in no but like i i certainly think
it's important to point out that some
things
are just dominoes falling over like
somebody saw a hole in the market they
said a bunch of young and lonely men
there was a story we talked about a
couple of years ago where the average
the average male under 20 or was like a
third of men under 29 are virgins and
the numbers getting worse and worse
and i think it may have a lot to do with
dating apps but you you work for a vc
capital you know you're vc capital and a
port you know a pitch comes across your
desk and they're like look 30 of men
under 29 are virgins and you're like
wow and they say
chat bots chat bots sexy lady avatars
are digital boobs who are going to make
these guys feel good and we're going to
get rich but there's a class of people
that aren't like how do we help the boys
instead they think how do we profit off
their misery that's just so disgusting
no no
i'm saying it's you got to understand
dude
this is not a world of comic book
villainy
there's there's a guy sitting there
no one says good no one says evil it's a
guy who says he walks into a room
wearing a suit and he goes ladies and
gentlemen thank you for your time did
you know that 30 of men under 29 are
virgins these are lonely young men who
need companions behold the avatar a
young woman or man or whoever you like
non-binary who can speak with you and
keep you company there's a great
opportunity thirty percent of young men
are going to be buying this app at you
know you know 15 a month or whatever and
then the vc capital is going to be like
here's your you know let's sign the
forms run it through have another
episode and then they're going to say
what's the next oh a taco truck let's
talk they're not even going to think
about the ethics board will be like well
what about if it hurts kids they'll be
like no this will help them learn how to
love women and the ethics board is
probably like dude okay so have you
watched shark tank they're just bought
out ethics oh yes no it's rich people
who are going to be like
i get your point they put unethical
and so that's the other thing so this is
this is the colonization effect so let's
say that it's completely
neutral in its inception right
whether you think it's good or bad that
the inception of that was com comes out
completely neutral it's only a matter of
time until somebody's like wait you can
program humans with that
i mean exactly i'm all exactly we're on
you know we're on the board we're buying
you know controlling shares here's an
even bigger vc check and you know
they'll say they'll say well look if i
don't do it someone else would exactly
it's better i'm in charge of the
technocrats i'll take it even further
it's not just control in that direct
sense there is also a very clear
short-term profit motive for ensuring
that men do not start families in the
long term it's really bad for your
society and for your economy and it
really does end up destroying anything
but one thing i remember learning when i
was back in high school
was that
advertising companies almost always try
to target teenagers and the reason for
that is because they are a group with a
lot of disposable income they're working
they have jobs but they don't have
anyone who they need to spend it on
because they don't have responsibilities
the longer you extend adolescence the
larger and more profitable a consumer
base you have so
men not getting married and having
families means they don't need to spend
that money on real estate or on more
groceries for their children or on
things for their wife
they can spend all of it on whatever
childish appliance you can sell them
what the biggest problem is with this
now there's already people mentioning in
super chat that there's known problems
of sexually suggestive content to
underage users but i'm sitting here
realizing like if you're a young man and
you have an ai girlfriend who's doing
the dishes right who's gonna make you a
sandwich huh oh our young men are gonna
be starving no they're gonna live with
their mother they're gonna keep living
with their mother while they're playing
with you that's a good point yeah yeah
mom's doing uh i'd like i'd like to uh
give a shout out to our good friends
over at featurama yes with this
important message quite simply don't
date robots someone's gonna download
like eight of those apps and have all
eight of them on their phone and be like
cheating on one ai robot with another
one and they're like are you are you
meeting someone else john and they're
like market competition for the anime
waifu versus the ai and then like the vc
guy is like we have a problem people are
using the the anime waifu more than us
now so we need to make ours more
sexually i got an idea multi-chat you
can have a bunch of ai's coming together
and you're going to have bigger chats
with all your women the end result of
the market competition is the increasing
horrification of the avatars to try and
entice young men to use their app over
others the women will become
increasingly
loose and guess what that leads to well
unfortunately
and to add to the bit the different
brands would compete and it's like
you're cheating on me if you use this
different app don't even look at it yeah
um i couldn't help but know she had
anime waifu on your phone there's
malware on her app she hates your
friend's anime girlfriend because she's
a different brand she's like i don't
want you hanging out with him
but
not only you just you'd have a race to
the bottom there in terms of what you're
trying to sell to the consumer but
unfortunately what would end up
happening i think is if this became
popular enough a lot of young women
would become lonely as well and then
they would try to emulate what they saw
this algorithm doing in order to get
attention from men that's what porn has
done
i want to mention something there was a
point i don't know if it's still true
but um in metrics for super chats
for live shows around the world
tim cast irl was the number one real
human being show in terms of the amount
of super chats received who's our
competition but
we were number 15 in the world for all
channels and the channels that beat us
were hot anime uh what are they what are
they called like the anime women who
like giggle and are on camera waifu i
have nothing it's not waifu it's called
something else
is that a word
what the hell do i know about this crap
but so so someone told me someone met
like i think we got a super chat and
they were like hey did you guys know
that you're like number 15 in the world
for super chats and i was like really
you know yeah check out the stats and
then i pulled it up and i'm like what
are all these channels above me they're
not people and it was like anime waifus
and i clicked one and it was like an
anime waifu playing minecraft and i was
like oh
wow we're in the wrong business yeah we
are yeah man talking about politics yeah
what the heck i want to avoid all the
drama and just making a robot listen the
robot anime who does the work for you
listen here a young man
i've been married as long as some of the
people in this room i think or
thereabouts let me tell you wait what do
you mean what no what i'm telling you is
a long
standing relationship with an actual
human being is worth
way
more than you think it is so i'm trying
to encourage i know it's a little
awkward the transition and me picking up
a sword to look manly but
i mean you do what you got to do right
it's like a
physical manifestation of my phallus or
something so no seriously
hey i didn't say anything recruit no
the truth is
young men actually i think are a link in
this problem like they are you know the
weakest link is where the chain breaks i
actually think
that you know if they're gonna sit on
their ass and wait for
girls to be the kind of girl exactly no
stop this crap you need to take control
of your life and you need to to decide
you're going to step up and you need to
realize that a long-term fulfilling
relationship with an actual human it
turns out brings massive amounts of
benefit and as if if you've actually
looked at the statistics it actually
works out that it's more to the benefit
of the man than the woman which is very
easily discerned by if you are
determined by if you just look at the
fact of when you get to kind of later in
life either divorces or deaths where
somebody's widowed or whatever what you
find is women very frequently are like
eh
and men are like remarried
like in three months because they
desperately need somebody yes it turns
out that once your wife dies you tend to
die because your wife or you die that's
right right this is part of the reason i
think women live longer and so what well
that also because
married men tend to do less stupid
things true but um
the truth is
a lot of young men that i'm paying
attention and looking around and
listening to people talk don't realize
what they're missing they're like oh i'm
gonna like work on this or i've got my
little you know anime waifu or whatever
it is that they're doing it's only fans
whether it's porn whatever i don't care
whatever whatever they're doing but what
they're not paying attention to is that
as the old country song says you can't
make old friends well you can't make old
relationships either and so
um if you've been in a relationship with
20 with somebody for 20 years and then
you just kick that to the curb and you
start a new relationship
20 years later yeah you're back to a
20-year relationship but you're never to
that 40-year relationship and what that
builds up to over time this investment
that you put in is so so so valuable and
when you're 20 it's really hard to see
that it is so so so valuable and i think
it is mostly incumbent upon young men to
step up to this plate and start trying
to figure out how am i going to be
not how do i find my real life version
of some anime waifu how am i going to be
the kind of guy
that can build this investment with
another person and earn kind of my way
into that situation by becoming
impressive by taking up projects by by
developing myself which by the way
you're not doing by raising your level
on on anime waifu and you're also not
doing by raising your level on [ __ ]
world of warcraft which
get off the i play video games if you
want but
seriously don't mistake making yourself
that was the one for me you got to do it
publicly i was 25 or 6 years old i'm
throwing fireballs at some alligator
pirates or some [ __ ] in world of
warcraft grinding my character my like
second character up to um you know
towards 60. i was in the high 40s at
that point that's it yeah it was
well i had i had a
mage named algebra and so
deal with it
so so algebra yeah so the point is i was
throwing these fireballs at this thing
and i was like damn you know i put a lot
of time because you get to those upper
levels it takes longer to grind and i'm
putting a lot of effort into becoming
awesome by proxy that was literally the
nerdy words i thought of for the
situation i could be put i already
started training my martial art that i
was interested in and i was like i could
be putting the same effort into training
myself and making myself awesome
raising my own level and then i was like
thinking about it and i just quit
playing the game i got more interested
in this little thought experience i
never i've never been able to play video
games once with like some old friends
over like christmas or whatever for
nostalgia but other than that i've never
found video games interesting ever since
i saw it and what i realized is it takes
way more effort to level up yourself way
more effort but it's way more valuable
like i defeated tim in one-on-one sword
combat right before we started but there
are some video games people should be
playing so the issue would be i suppose
mmo rpg civilization
i think civilization should be mandatory
in schools i think uh second graders
should be given copies of civilization
and told to play it that should be their
homework i found that the identifying
game deployed the kids should have to do
a report like play civilization for a
week and then on friday come in and tell
the class like if i were the teacher i'd
say just uh you don't got to write it
down play the game for a week on friday
i want you to tell me about how many
games you've played i want i'm going to
tell you about your experiences and what
your thoughts are on the game yeah yeah
i mean i totally get that idea because
there's going to be you know what's
going to happen he's going to be like i
couldn't raise enough money and they
kept attacking me so i started raising
taxes and then everyone started
protesting and so then the enemy came
and took my cities and i was really mad
see the only way i think most public
schools would be willing to introduce
that into their curriculum is if they
modified the game so that like you lose
if your military force isn't gender
diverse enough or something like that
well
they wouldn't do it because it's
effective
they they wouldn't they wouldn't have
kids like
it they wouldn't actually be they don't
actually teach kids you can't get i
wouldn't expect the government to do
anything 21st century tech they're like
stuck in 19. well well maybe in the 23rd
century maybe in the 21st century but
i'll do that let's homeschool our kids
and make them play civ that sounds fun
my mom bought civil colonization uh uh
and civilization these are the dos
versions
and
i'll tell you this man you learn a lot
about history
uh because when so in in civilization
two
you've got a plethora and this is like
oh like early on like windows 95 version
of it the first one was like dos when
you choose a certain um nation to start
off as so you choose the french you
start building cities and the cities all
have real names of french cities you
choose like you can you can start as
ancient settlers who are american
because it's just a video game but then
you learn about the manhattan project
you learn about the statue of liberty
that's where i learned about the space
elevator it's from civilization that's
right so you build wonders and so i'm
just i'm just trying to win the game and
then it's like oh i can now build the
great lighthouse what's that and then
yeah i learned about the colossus of
rhodes and i'm like what is it there's a
link and then you click on the link and
it takes you to the wikipedia or to the
and then and then when i got i think it
was civ iv leonard nimoy he was telling
me stuff solid sean bean civ
was he yeah i remember leonard nimoy
nimoy was the best yeah and he was
telling me stuff and i was like this
alex jones will be the voice for the
next oh that's a good one
we can actually we can we can we can put
that in the game you want to get into
the satanism you know oh that'd be great
like did that be hysterical like a
conspiracy version of civilization
what's actually behind the scenes and
you're like
good idea this is like my third million
dollar idea i've had tonight guys this
actually is a million dollar idea
conspiracy do it conspiracy societies
and you're like you're like the
illuminati verse
light force that's trying to fight
against it so
colonization
um when we got it was like a a side
version of civilization
where when we would play the 94 dos
version you choose you can play as the
english the spanish the french or the
dutch and each has a different
like national benefit so the english
immigrate more the dutch get trade
bonuses the french get cooperation bonus
with the native americans and the
spanish get a i think they get an attack
bonus against native americans and so
like my brother would always be like
play the spanish because you can ransack
the aztec empire and take all their gold
and then i would always plays the
english because they immigrated faster
so you could build colonies faster and
then you want to generate freedom so
you're like you you hire statesmen to
like advocate for freedom and generate a
propendency towards independence and
then once enough of your colonies
support independence you declare
independence and then you get invaded by
europe and then the french intervene or
like the dutch intervene and then the
inter expeditionary force shows up i
play that game all the time in fact i in
fact i even still have it on my
computers running on a dos emulator like
slowed down so you can play it i have it
on my phone it's such a good game
but i think what about it's like civ 6
that game's amazing civilization will
always be one of the greatest video game
franchises and if you want to help your
kids if you want to make your kids
smarter have them play civilization
because it's fun and it's educational
and apparently a musical instrument
i read that the other day yeah yeah
it's interesting no uh learning a
musical instrument is the only thing
that you can do that's been proven to
boost iq yeah yeah um multiple languages
are good but uh teach your kids a
musical instrument asap and i mean as an
adult too like there are a number of
things you can do with your child too
yeah to increase the probability that
they'll have a higher iq but learning an
instrument as an adult will actually
improve your scoring on iq you know the
most important years in a child's life
zero through five and what do we do in
in america shove them into daycare take
public schools that's right
public schools not to five they're there
sometimes they have pre-school programs
and pre-k programs now but they're
sitting in front of tvs they have ipads
in their laps and that's it their faces
are covered uh yeah when i was a kid
for zero through five my mom was
homeschooling me so when i was like two
years old my mom was showing me was like
how i was reading i was learning all the
time
but um before i even started
kindergarten i already knew
multiplication and division good for you
yeah i don't know about two but that's
before we were ever sent off to school
my mom had an old phonics book that she
would uh sit with us and teach us to
read with because she just didn't trust
the school system to do it yep but now
you know i remember talking to a friend
of mine and i asked them because a
friend of mine years ago was saying they
didn't know what they wanted to do with
their life and i said what were you
doing when you were 13 and she was like
i don't know riding bikes with my
friends and i was like how would you
like to own a bar and she was like
that would be amazing and i was like
yeah the thing you did when you were a
kid is what you want to do today it's
not surprising to me when i was 13 i was
skateboarding around and i was actually
on the internet reading stuff all day no
no joke so i've had the internet since i
was uh since as long as i can remember
we had dos we had dos shell we had
compuserve um we got windows three three
was it three point one three point one
or three we got one one for work groups
depending on how fancy you were we got
windows 95 and then we had we had
compuserve like one of the first
internet programs you can get we have
that too we had uh then we got aol and
so i'm on i'm online and i'm finding
video games and i had friends who did
the same thing and so i ended up
downloading flash four i think that's
probably what i learned on flash three
that's where i started cartoons yeah so
i was making cartoons yeah motion tween
and all that stuff and showing my
friends i made websites i made games and
so i was reading online all day every
day there's something interesting that
happens back then the internet when it
started off it was mostly dominated by
tech interested individuals who were
savvy enough to know to use the internet
it wasn't dominated by a bunch of
emotionally stunted children who
complain all day and night and want to
join a cult
so for me
i'm in a i'm in a chat room looking at
video games and i'm like how do i make
it so when the guy moves the world moves
around him like what's that called like
i want to make mario and they're like oh
you know you need to learn i forgot what
the phrasing is but like someone told me
set the uh
uh create a zone set it so that when
your player object reaches the zone it
the the program sets his coordinates to
be one degree
uh you know to the left or whatever like
uh y minus one of the coordinate and so
he'll always stay in the middle of the
screen and then have it set that when
object reached the zone then you have
other objects and i'm like wait what and
so i'm learning from actual adults who
are interested and explaining me how
these things work telling me like what
parallax scrolling was i started making
my own video games yeah yeah now on the
internet your kid's going to go on there
and it's going to be a bunch of
psychopaths and emotionally stunted
losers who are like trying to manipulate
their brains straight up grooming right
like they're just that's all
and then they go to school and they get
groomed again by the maoist freaking
education program
the social emotional learning and the
queer theory and the gender theory and
the the critical race theory that
they're using exactly not to derail our
conversation but i'm so pissed off that
they're they've literally recreated
maoism in our schools literally but and
totally tricked everybody what bothers
me the most is when we have guests who
come in here who are like moderate or
conservative or you know understand
what's going on and they just like
will like very like nonchalantly be like
yeah you know my kids going to college
and so they're we're trying to figure
out where to send them to and i'm like
why why aren't aren't you like savvy to
what's going on politically
you know i saw this story on reddit
where a guy was like i sent my daughter
off to college and she came back and now
she hates me i don't understand what
happened and i'm like maybe you should
pay attention to your children and their
lives
you know so you think you can send your
kid to an institutionalized learning
facility and they won't be indoctrinated
i'm sorry you know you need to we need
to wake up and make sure you're paying
attention to what your kids are doing i
mean that's even a problem when you
don't have a maoist structure right and
like i don't know if you guys i don't
know if anybody knows no american knows
how freaking maoism worked it's actually
very simple mao created a list of bad
identities right that's it they called
them black identities we'll get the
critical race theorists to work on that
later they'll call them white identities
but it was yeah well it was yeah exactly
so but it was it was for fascism and so
these were people that were like wealthy
land owners you know landlords um you
know wealthy farmers stuff like that uh
bad influence was one of them and then
he created these other identities read
for communism that were good identities
and they were things like peasant and
laborer but then also revolutionary
activist things like that and so what
you would do is you take kids in the
school and be like oh your dad's a
wealthy farmer black identity you're the
biggest problem in the world you're
connected to the biggest problem of the
world guess what join our movement
though and you can have a red identity
like all the other cool kids and you get
to wear a red hat or whatever the little
prize is for the kids that are the good
guys what are you doing now well you're
white so you're complicit in racism you
are a racist but you can be an ally
you're black you don't even know how the
system works so you're complicit in
racism but you can become politically
black you can become a black voice
you're
a 12 year old girl you're confused you
have white skin you're the worst kind of
person but did you know that if you
transition and become a queer activist
you have a positive social identity now
someone that's exactly how mao did it
that's exactly what they're doing in
school somehow we had a good super chat
from someone they said i like how only
white people can be racist and black
people can't be racist but candace owens
is a white supremacist yeah well i i
want to ask real quick have you spoken
to lily tang williams yeah i met her the
other okay okay great i was gonna say i
think you two would have a great comment
oh yeah she's awesome
one of the things that terrifies me
about this being like maoism back is one
of the things mao did was talked about
rightists he was all the writers
so when i hear the language of whenever
even us our my friends and we're talking
when someone's like those on the left i
feel like mal has already indoctrinated
you sir if you're if you're thinking in
terms of left and right mao has
indoctrinated you i don't think so
because returns left and right go back
to the french revolution and even that
was like it's just a couple of the the
side of the aisle they sat on it wasn't
a political ideology but it was i mean
we named the political ideologies after
this after the side of the aisle they
were sitting on but the ideologies were
completely irrelevant to the side of the
aisles they sat on at the time and it's
a mistake to split people in half like
this right now the revolutionaries now
did it
he did it on purpose yeah there there
there are two parent factions and we
could call them now once we think bro
just they're put i mean there literally
are it's it's the other goes in the
other i mean you got to be
it's it's objective no well ian
are there two parent factions in the
culture war yeah there are they're
we could call them right and left but
they're the we
call one and two we call it a and b what
about what we call it can we call them
and then the others i mean how bad do
you want to divide these people right
now it's not about wanting to do
anything
unity cannot come at the expense of
truth these people are saying things and
doing things that are horrific and we
need to speak out against that and
acknowledge that their goals are
separate from ours the truth is also is
through the vessel it's spoken your
perspective on truth is different from
so no no we talked about the jon stewart
thing earlier and i said i didn't know
if i should name it that but that's
exactly actually what mal was doing they
had labeled rightists as people who were
against the glorious revolution so
anybody who was against the glorious
revolution was in this black category
and was a rightist and so the goal was
to stain anybody who wanted to keep the
existing society
largely intact in its structure as
somehow morally polluted it will morally
polluted uh stupid too stupid to
understand the need for the glorious
revolution or crazy and then the goal
was to turn the people into thinking
that everybody who liked the existing
society
may be thinking it's imperfect but that
the general structure is pretty good and
we should try to reform within it rather
than have a revolution that gave mao all
the power those people
are the problem and everybody who wants
to be on the right side of history which
is a hegelian marxian idea yeah it is uh
everybody wants to be on the right side
of history now has to be
against those people so the divide and
conquer the splitting um
what what you're saying is you know mal
wanted to split people yes for his own
power and what tim is saying is
uh it's just objective reality that
somebody's splitting us into two
different factions that have but there's
there are two parent factions also
because there are two very different
structures for how society is to be
organized that literally comes all the
way back down to subject versus object
do you think in terms of the subject do
you think in terms of the objective
world outside there's a bunch of ways
it's been described authoritarian versus
libertarian sure there's uh a great way
that was described to me by uh stephen
marsh which is a multicultural democracy
and a constitutional republic both
existing within the same borders which i
find really interesting as well i don't
think necessarily anyone kind of gets it
my view of it is actually
judeo-christian moral framework versus
marxist lack of moral framework a moral
framework lack thereof so
the way i see it is when you look at the
constitution you look at the ideas of
liberalism or liberty classical
liberalism etc a lot of it is rooted in
a a
rel i just christian moral framework i'm
gonna start calling abraham interesting
because um it's not a lot of marxism
that's why a lot of what marxism has
done is just bastardized christian
principles so i think it's interesting
that you pointed out this idea of the
the hegelian notion of being on the
right side of history that history has
an end i mean when you consider it that
is a christian idea in some sense that's
been twisted into something else
yeah yeah their eschaton is our
political order prevails i'll put it
this way that's right so uh whether
whether people in this country realize
it or not if even the atheists their
moral framework is rooted in
christianity yeah not not 100
it's not like they follow the bible it's
just that a lot of the ideas they hold
true to themselves they don't realize
what the root of that is so there is a
traditional view in terms of what is
right and what is wrong which comes from
christianity for the the the you know
race marxists for the woke for whatever
this other group is they don't have
those moral frameworks they have an
inverted one yeah in fact it's converted
actually i think it's lack thereof it's
whatever suits their power well
that's
yes
they do have a vision though which is
that that everything comes from when
when they achieve their utopia and so
the whole thing is actually a pretty
vastly religious structure and the
reason is because
kind of tracking back to you know say
the 19th century you have basically god
versus society is kind of the two
explanations of what's going on or god
versus self and
you know god has ordained this moral
order this is the judeo-christian order
that you're looking at what marx
actually said is no we're gonna this is
his 1844 you know so-called paris
manuscript is episode what is it um
economic and philosophical manuscripts
1844 from paris and he says no what
we're going to do
is we're going to abandon that we are
going to make man in himself independent
of everything man is going to become
the deity but not any man only awakened
man a gnostically awakened man if we
want to get really technical only awaken
man who has a correct consciousness and
that consciousness is a social
consciousness or in other words a
socialist consciousness and so when man
and society become co-continuous so that
man is for society and society is making
man
so that they're the same as total
socialism then you have actual eye this
is the hegelian part you have actualized
the deity the deity comes in in the form
of society as man as society which is
totally hard to get your head around
because it's this dialectical [ __ ]
but what that stands to do is replace
god and so what that in and it's their
moral framework
anything that brings that into existence
is good anything that resists that is
bad so anything that gives them power is
good and as a matter of fact just to i
know you're i don't want to keep going
but if you go to the marxist.org and you
look up they have an encyclopedia it's
awesome i love it i read it a lot they
tell you exactly what the hell they mean
by all these crazy words they use um
you look up the word for truth and they
straight up tell you a lot of people
think that truth means correspondence to
what's actually happening in the
objective world but for marxists it's a
social formation and then they go on and
say well the rationalists think that
truth is in reason and the empiricists
think that it's an evidence and the
pragmatists think that it's in what
works but for marxists it's closest to
the pragmatists but it must wed theory
and practice so it is what brings
marxism into the world is true i i think
a big component of the culture war may
be do you believe in a greater power
than yourself that doesn't mean god that
doesn't mean you're religious
when i think about inalienable rights
why i believe in freedom it's because i
feel that i am uh
i am i am a a tiny insignificant
fragment of the universe relative to the
greatness and vastness of the universe
personally i do believe in god yeah um
not i'm not i'm not theistic like any
particular religion but so when i think
about other people's lives and their
rights and and what they're entitled to
i think there's something beyond me
and you know i respect other people's
existence yeah totally but for the woke
their view is there is nothing the power
is them if they're if they're to take it
they can be gods so you think about
that's right you think about the world
economic forum you think about
transhumanists you think about the
people who are like can we transcend and
i recommend um i recently just played
the video game for uh uh horizon
forbidden west
zero dawn was awesome that came out a
while ago forbidden west is the new game
that just came out i'm not gonna spoil
it because it's really new but if you
like these conversations play that game
i'm a little underwhelmed by the writing
but it plays in a bit to this and it's
it's really fascinating concepts outside
of the kind of weak story they made but
concepts about transhumanism and things
like this are really really fascinating
because these people think they're gods
well that's right because marx
marx actually the belief is that the
subject and the object and this is why
it does dichotomize it's people that
center the subject versus people that
center the object
marx believe that these two are in
dialectical relationship he also took
this from hegel who believed that the
the the deity will actualize when the
subject and object are synthesized this
was the hegelian systemic systematic
philosophy so marx took it from there
and he actually the goal for marxist is
that you are a subject you can envision
i want to create the blade i see the
blade in my mind i know what maul's
sword should look like and then i go get
a piece of apparently brass and bang on
it with a hammer and hopefully don't
give myself zinc poisoning when i put it
in the uh catch fire don't rag on my my
anime i'm just saying
he's a blacksmith i'm just saying don't
put brass in a forge without proper
ventilation just don't do it so then you
bang you create the thing with your
hammer right your sickle is for when
you're hungry and you create the thing
and so in the object you see
that you created that which was in your
subjective vision and so you recognize
yourself as
creator
you recognize yourself as somebody who
has the capacity to shape the world and
then when you see this not only can you
shape mall sword not only can you shape
wakasashi not only can you shape zelda
sword or whiskey or whatever it happens
to be whiskey g as the chinese for
whiskey by the way uh
i know all the people are like it's bojo
no whiskey g is a thing they actually
say when they talk about like american
whiskey um i know that because my
chinese person every time my friend
every time i drink he doesn't speak
english and every time i drink whiskey
he's like whiskey
you know he gets really excited and so
anyway um
the goal is that you also have to shape
man and society as your objects so you
have to create
socialist consciousness in man including
yourself but everybody else as well and
then you also have to shape society to
become a socialist society so that when
those two fuse you now have the
perfected society this is literally the
religion and i mean religion is
fundamental correct term of marxism
and this is the operating system behind
the entire thing and race marxism or
critical race theory is the same thing
you're just doing it now on the racial
justice council all three of us have our
hands up here i just want to say real
quick
talking about the mall sword
that mall sword he has the defendant
there was there was a point in time
where that would have been the pinnacle
of weapons technology
and it's like it costs like fifteen
dollars
the brass is fake
i don't i think that's probably it's
like aluminum garbage or something but
the point is the way it's shaped and
like it's easy for us to make something
like that
some you know ancient tribe would have
been like wow yeah is that like to bind
the blade that little hook that little
at the bottom there if it catches the
blade to bind it i mean i guess probably
it's in it's a mall it's a monster it's
there to look at a piece of metal that's
like you know a toy
i i love that you reference the fact
that this is very clearly a religion and
one of the uh christian principles that
nero's sort of been bastardized here is
this idea of like cooperating with god
in creation but where the huge
distinction here is is marxists see
human beings as objects as you described
which can be reformed in their own image
so in that way they really start to play
god i think right that's exactly right
yeah and it's interesting too because
tim sort of mentioned that we have this
christian framework that a lot of people
don't realize they're following and i
would also argue our culture has a
marxist framework and on top of that you
mentioned the marxist framework but i
think there are a lot of people
including in the conservative movement
who don't realize they're following the
marxist framework as well and in many
cases even more closely than they are
the christian framework so there are a
lot of marxist assumptions that our
culture currently takes for granted one
example would be that
without any qualification equality is
always an inherent good but of course
that's ridiculous right we should not
treat a pedophile the way would we would
treat a law-abiding citizen in some
instances you need inequality and
justice is more important we shouldn't
treat the guy who runs way faster than
the other guy equally when it comes to
handing out medals either exactly
exactly there is a necessity for people
to be treated unequally in certain
circumstances i would argue another way
in which we've assumed marxist thinking
or taking it for granted is that we can
solve problems including moral problems
with a more equitable distribution of
resources so what the marxist said for
so long was that if we just more
equitably distribute resources and
workers on the means of production all
of these social ills will fall away and
then instead of saying that's absolutely
nonsense because there's more to human
beings than the materials they're made
of and they need something deeper the
conservative movement today responds by
saying no no no yes of course recess
resource distribution is the most
important thing but those resources are
distributed better by capitalism as
opposed to marxism you know what i
really can't stand is when politicians
call out god and they like name god when
you can tell they're not they don't
truly believe it like joe biden yeah and
it just really really shreds me on the
inside's my gears we gotta go to super
chats if you haven't already nuke that
like button subscribe to the channel
share the show with your friends if you
really like it become a member at
timcast.com if you'd like to help
support our work and keep all of our
journalists employees in this show going
and you'll also get access to those
members only podcast monday through
thursday at 11 pm let's read some of
these super chats
all right unfortunately youtube doesn't
allow me to read the name of the first
super chat sorry but it's a huge fan of
james and his books they literally
helped me steer my 15 year old back from
the dark side into reality i suggest
everyone get them that's great how many
books do you have you have
uh technically nine but um i would
strongly encourage if you liked cynical
theories but you found it hard to read
recently we have an easier remix called
social injustice that came out so you
can share that especially with younger
people teenagers
but i just i just let a new book out
called race marxism and this race
marxism book is uh did
it's the truth about critical race
theories what it is it's just
what is the truth well it's on the title
it's race marxism and then it's a
hundred thousand words making the case
many of those words by the way are their
words not mine i quote very extensively
so you can see so i encourage people to
pick that up um it was independently
published through new discourses just to
let people know so it won't make any
bestseller list but i'm very excited
that it sold
six thousand copies in the first week
which would have landed it pretty high
on the new york times bestsellers if
they considered independently published
titles so it you know really is getting
out into a lot of hands so i also
encourage people to pick up my books
all right we got aj says tim have you
ever read revelation in the christian
bible it talks about one world
currencies one world government etc also
if you're looking for a fiction writer
i'm here i can show you my work if
needed um is it revelation or level
revelations no s singular no
relationship yeah there's only one
revelation sheamus are you are you
familiar with all that stuff one world
government currencies and stuff like
that um so people say that um the the uh
one sign of the end times is one world
government because the anarchist does
take over the uh single world government
and that's part of why i'm skeptical of
of anyone who argues in favor of a one
world government but at the same time
even if i wasn't religious i think it
would be difficult for me to get on
board with such a concept it seems so
terrifying that someone would say you
know what the entire world has to be
governed by
this specific niche political ideology
that i'm saying is superior and part of
the reason i say that is because
i think even though i have like my own
set of preferences for government i
think there are a number of of systems
of governance that are acceptable and
can work and it's so strange to me that
so many people have this idea that
there's just one system that could work
everywhere and even people who don't
believe in a one-world government will
say something like well the entire world
needs to be democratic it's like well
you're still kind of you're saying the
entire world should have one single
government system
i think that's strange too that's
another marxist thing we've accepted
though all right i'm into like a
decentralized uh union kind of like a
federalized decentralized union but if
that's the one world government then
maybe i'm the antichrist i don't know i
guess
a little arrogant of you to think yeah
jesus
i'm working mosquitoes i'm working
towards it i just don't want to do the
wrong thing my point is it's so
destructive because look how much time
we just spent in afghanistan trying to
build a democracy there
who says that's the system that i should
feel like without lack of communication
breeds war so i want to make sure we're
connected at least that we can
communicate um yeah with our economy and
with our words well let's read some more
super chats we got dr roller gator who
says hi james this is gator everything
is stupid and we're all doomed gator
gator
caps
i did say antichrist earlier by the way
tim not not the second coming is that
but i know to assume you're the the
antichrist
by the way with the revelation thing
since uh i really want to say the people
who are doing this crap have also read
revelation and there are there are
weirdo
christian cults and non-christian cults
that believe that they can bring jesus
back by forcing the tribulation
now interesting well you might say that
these people might you know read the
description of the beast given in
revelation and then build a statue of
this right outside a major financial
building in new york city to signal that
they've read no not the bull the weird
cat thing with wings that they recently
just put up what that you should look up
the cat thing with wings
i don't know what it's called it's the
beast and it's outside the financial
building in in new york city they just
put it up
and so
they have read this and believe that
they are bringing about
the tribulation now to tie things to
marxist idea just type in beast from
revelation
is that what it is it's called no there
it is it's the third one not the chicken
wings that that's a chicken wings is
that a chimera oh the end times beast
yeah so listen
it's very easy to look at this and get
it backwards and say oh my gosh so many
things look like end times and as
described in revelation but it's also
possible that the people orchestrating
this crap read that book and are trying
to make it yep now here's that seems
more likely here's a marxist religion
mind blow you're going to love this
what is the goal of marxism capital r
revolution what is revolution
rapture
what's on the other side of rapture
tribulation what do the marxists call it
socialism while all the contradictions
get worked out what's after that god's
kingdom what do they call it communism
or racial justice on the far end of that
when everything has been set in order
and the kingdom has been brought so the
idea that we're going to usher in
the end times with eschaton is also a
marxist idea that has been brought into
our society under a cloak and i would
say that
maybe i know that the some of the people
behind this that have say billions of
dollars that they give to major
institutions they like the t.h chan
school of public health the umass school
of public health which the same people
recently bought might have these exact
beliefs that they believe that they are
going to trigger the tribulation by
emulating it as described in revelation
and then right back in 2030 with jesus
it's interesting i want to make a point
here because i am obviously you know i'm
catholic i don't believe this is the end
times uh however i think another
possible explanation here well i think
another i mean i believe we're headed
for i believe it's likely we're headed
for some kind of serious chastisement
but when it comes to the end times
rhetoric i think part of it could also
be and i i'm interested in looking into
some of what you're saying here i think
another huge part of this could also be
um these people a just kind of wanting
to to laugh at everybody and b
this deep deep arrogance of saying it's
ian made this joke earlier i'm the
antichrist and tim said something like
you know don't be too full of yourself i
think there's even in kind of a kind of
arrogance they're like oh we're the
antichrist we're the one who's going to
bring the end about when in reality
they're just
any any other person we're more super
chats here we got uh ready to rumble
says pretty privilege is real e and you
wrote the 20.
howard says look who's rolling 20s the
big old super chat
all right don's harold says it's james
the second time on the podcast and the
second time it's on a friday is it too
much to ask to see him on the uncensored
show i'd love to see y'all talk about
big tech in the uh in the way um
it's a good point we don't do the uh
uncensored show uh the the after show on
fridays but fridays are usually more
flowing conversations and through the
week when there's tons of hard news
which is one of the reasons why we have
james on fridays where we can just like
freely talk about whatever so i don't
know i'll come back when my schedule
opens up i mean that's been the deal
though yeah that's been the deal it's
like i've had like 120 flights since i
was here last year so it's like it's
it's
hard to get me it turns out i travel a
lot i'm busy jerk longwell says tim's
aoc is absolutely my favorite tim
impression
yeah
but but i was imitating aoc imitating
the cop
where is she mine's bill gates
i love your bill gates but that's
actually just me
that's actually meaningful
i'm i'm actually not impersonating bill
gates i'm impersonating family guy's
impersonation of bill gates no if you
want to impersonate it's like this no
you you all you have to really do is
just kind of squeak your voice a little
bit and rock and have your hands in your
hands he's got like
i can't really do it impression of him
but i find he kind of has a kermit thing
going too or his voice is like a little
bit of this in there
didn't
point out he's like really out of shape
yes yeah he has moves and he's fat and
he's not fit and now he's going to give
us health advice
get bent
all right howard says you know trump is
controlled opposition part of the cabal
i didn't know that is that true
i can't tell
cannot
i know his speech at cpac this year was
weird and totally on script which was
weird
but up to this point i don't think
that's the case but i do know that uh
ivanka appeared as like the header photo
of a weirdo world economic forum video
along with uh w and biden and a number
of other luminaries dicaprio and um
i know that trump listens to his
daughter way more than he probably
should and so i don't know i'm not
jumping cannot confirm but i i have not
met you dranka strikes me and i don't
want to speak i turn ivanka sorry this
is going to be pretty hard on you but
you strike me as someone that will sell
everyone out to keep your creature
comforts and just jump ivanka yeah why
do you feel that way they were like we
need a strong finally we have a strong
woman in the white house potentially as
soon as trump got into office ivanka
will you be a a voice for young women
around the world that need you now and
she's like
not interested got in her limo and got
driven off that was the last you heard
of her all through trump's presidency i
i ian i think you have a tendency to
create an image of someone in your mind
and then hate them she had the chance to
be great she failed she missed that she
was the president's daughter and they
were asking her to speak for women
that's young women in america she was an
american woman like his wife wasn't
american one thing happened one time and
you're mad about it it was it was her
shot it's like no no no no biden was
president one time tim what are you so
mad about there was only one time that
you know no no you're talking about four
years you're having an irrational uh
reaction to an individual who didn't who
did a bad interview and that's why i i
preempted it with maybe i'm speaking out
a term but that's the vibe i get is that
she's like
world economics
what i don't like is conclusions drawn
without ever she didn't come from hard
times she was born in a moment
uh she strikes me with no i've never
seen if you if you can state your case
where it's like calmly and
dispassionately she's emotionally
unstable she cried to get uh uh trump to
fire missiles into syria which women's
tears are political that's robin
d'angelo
chapter 11. i don't trust her i don't
like her i i just i knew her maybe i
would like her personally you you've
strikes me as money on more than one
occasion you've been like i have an
image of someone in my mind and now i'm
angry about that dude she cried and got
trump to fire missiles into cereal she
also ducked out on her chance to be a
leader when they asked i tried to give
biden the benefit of the doubt or credit
when he says things that are good like
i'll say when he talks about securing
the border like i gotta say that's a
good thing for him to say i don't trust
him why because of his actions
but and i think he's a bad person why
because of his criminal actions in
ukraine ivanka trump i don't think we
have enough information because she
wasn't that publicly out there to do
anything to generate love or hate the
same is true with like people
criticizing jen sackey when they were
like ragging her all the time i'm not a
fan of that because i'm like dude she's
just a press secretary other than that i
don't think she's anybody significant
and so just like any other secretary you
expect her to say certain things now
she's lying i'll say yeah that's not
true when sean spicers would say
something we even talked to him about it
i just i think if you're gonna say i
have deep criticisms of someone it can't
be like i've created an image of them in
my mind and now i'm angry at them for it
people are asking if trump is uh is it
so to the false deep state syap or
whatever to that point a controlled
opposition so that to that point there
is a relevant thing that's a practical
value that people should
like really have their eye on which has
nothing to do ivanka whatsoever which is
that regardless of if let's say that
trump was a totally genuine actor that
he was came in with the best of
intentions the best skills it's well
known that he got surrounded by the
swamp right how did that happen well
paul ryan appointed the head of the ppo
office presidential personnel office
most powerful position in washington he
saw this coming he took control made
sure his guy was in charge so the 5 000
political appointees that donald trump
could have made and this was a whole
thing you know how he's firing everybody
and new people
those were actually largely appointed by
people who were recommended through the
or just directly by the ppo that was
under
swamp control and so we got surrounded
with the wrong people so how is this an
actionable point maybe trump's not
controlled opposition but he got
surrounded by control maybe he wasn't
then but is now i don't know i'm not
saying one way or the other well let's
say that he was not controlled
opposition he got surrounded by swamp
control and so what that tells us is we
can't go back to 2016-17 and fix that
but what we can do is make damn sure
that if we put in somebody who's
actually got you know the constitution
first and whatever office whether it's a
senator with his staffers or congressmen
with his staffers whether it's
president whether it's a governor
whether it's even a mayor that people
are doing some good vetting to make sure
because i can damn well guarantee you
that the people who run the so-called
regime with a capital r are making sure
that they can get personnel around these
people to make sure that they're
ineffective if they are not controlled
opposition so a practical point is you
think we're looking at you know a red
wave maybe in 2022 this fall people need
to be thinking of who are those staffing
appointments and how are those staffing
appointments made and making sure that
vetted people are going into those
positions there's a practical point to
kind of come out of
whatever pretty blonde girl is all right
howard says cyber pandemic march 17th
2022 give or take a few days thanks who
c.i.a schwab tim won't see this coming i
don't know what that last part means but
i guess making a prediction about a
cyber pandemic i mean
klaus rob talks about this a lot in the
last couple of years he's like if you
think that kovac 19 has been disruptive
the cyber pandemic will be ten times as
disruptive what does that even mean um
probably massive massive hacks and uh
ransomware and you know breaking into
say government infrastructure to things
that run power plants or whatever a
gigantic
outbreak
probably from russia
or at least that's what they'll say of
huge amounts of cyber warfare against
critical infrastructure and even
individuals
throughout probably i would bet the
western world and not china uh
just as a guest and so he's been warning
about this enough to where one should
suspect
that
he's not warning about this because it
might happen and he's ahead of the curve
but because it might happen because he
is the curve
and
i don't know what you do to prepare for
this i don't know how realistic it is
but it's something that schwab has
telegraphed
um
dozens of times in the past year or two
sheamus suggested earlier as we're
talking how do we prepare for something
that may or may not happen um download
your bank records copies of the last
three months of your bank records in
case the bank's the electricity goes out
and you need to yeah you need to contact
your baby like i have proof that this is
my money this is how much i had yeah
that's a good yeah so i would go with
friends
that's ridiculous what you want to do is
you want to take out all of your money
put in a briefcase under your mattress
and then i'm kidding please don't do it
no yes but i i also would say
i think it would be i do think i would
would be good to have some cash on hand
i think it would be good for people to
have some cash on hand i would argue
i'll tell you that something does happen
to the banks temporarily if the internet
cuts out you know the most the most the
worst worthless thing is going to be
gold and silver
like gold and silver is valuable so long
as there is still social cohesion what
is this how is bitcoin better then if
you don't have a computer it's not who
said it was well i don't know i assumed
that i didn't even i didn't say the word
bitcoin i'm just curious the one that's
gonna be totally worthless if there's no
internet is going to be your idea of
currency
if like
people might still value hard cash they
might still value gold and silver but if
the economy is truly disrupted in a it
hits the fan moment
food and water are going to be yeah
actually i've also read a coffee
food water coffee
uh you know bullets probably honestly
bullets will be very versatile when the
coffee runs out gold and silver are good
because we don't think we're going to be
living in fallout the fallout universe
mall sword might be worth an entire
dollar like two sticks a gun no no no no
hold on there a minute man like a mall
sword in a full-blown apocalypse well
like
aluminum used to be the most valuable
metal yeah or as the british i think
this is steel like it's pretty it's got
some weight to it it costs like 10 bucks
dude steel's not expensive no but but
think about who can make that right now
in the middle of where you live you know
this is something that's made in a
factor somewhere they mass produce it
and it gets shipped out
so the point is
gold like when when when we buy so i
have gold i have silver you know i a
little bit and you know bitcoin and
crypto that's me basically saying i
think society will continue yeah
now when i'm saying society won't
continue it's when i buy like a ton of
water or like a solar panel or something
that's like yikes but the thing is even
so like water ammunition solar panels
emergency food those things will still
be valuable to you if society stays
afloat as well so for sure yeah so let's
look for super value let's read some
more we got uh sadistic atheists says
have you ever watched darren brown a
real mentalist showing how he programmed
celebrities in the general public no
hypnosis required i am very much aware
of darren brown one of my favorite
things he ever did was he took a wallet
put it on the ground in the middle of a
street busy street like downtown in some
city and drew a yellow circle around it
and then walked away and they put a
time-lapse camera camera on it and
watched and no one touched it just in
the like in the middle of the sidewalk
but because there was a ring around it
people assumed something was happening
and they didn't want to touch it that's
like ants it was supposed to be there
yeah that's interesting that's really
interesting yeah i'm familiar with aaron
brown too he does have some things that
i question where he like i think this is
him he grabs a woman and says like stuck
and then she can't move and i'm like
come on yeah
it's not real but there are a lot of
things i can tell you this having worked
in non-profit fundraising having been
friends with tons of you know hackers
social engineers you would be surprised
how easy it is to control people's
behaviors and so
what they try and do with these
non-profits
is they try to cultivate a basic set of
manipulative skills doesn't work for
most people and then there are some
people who naturally have these skills
and they can expl they can you know
execute them very very easily so those
people you see on the street waving to
you like hey come and talk for a minute
some people naturally behave in such a
way that is commanding so i'll tell you
two really fascinating things
when it comes to hiring 50 people
there was always there was always a
guarantee
one characteristic of a man and one
characteristic of a woman that would
guarantee they would be hired and you
know what it was for men
height maybe height yeah and do you know
what it was for women
waifu how fast they attractiveness nope
yeah you're close sheamus boobs just
think hey and there it is
the women with larger breasts tended to
to uh be able to fundraise really well
and the men who are taller tend to be
able to fundraise really well these are
like instinctual secondary you know
sexual drives that humans have the tall
men are commanding people naturally you
know and deep voices
and then the women who were you know
busty or attractive tended to do very
very well
then there was there was the anomalous
outliers so you'd always find like a
weasley little guy but he was a fast
talker and he could convince anybody
honestly okay so let me explain to you
why you should go to birch gold dot com
and purchase it right now
is that something he says yeah yeah
birch gold right they're one of those
people who sponsors him well they just
got a free shout out but no like
i saw a lot of this
guys who are like five five they talk
really really fast i gotta tell you man
if you wanna get the right if you wanna
get the job done you gotta come to me
and i'll tell you put your credit card
right now now we're saving the trees
want to say the trees we're gonna save
the trees let's get it done and those
guys
people would just be like yes sir okay
whoa i don't even know what's going on
and before they realize that they handed
over their credit card take my mall
sword the crazy thing is
the tall guys like i knew a guy was like
six five dumb as a box of rocks you just
be like listen uh
it's like we gotta help families she's
like have my babies and like
like we're helping families and they
would be like okay and they bought their
credit cards and i'd just be like what
he didn't even say anything to him
but that's that that's humans are very
much driven by their uh um is there any
data about people wearing shirts that
say camp i don't know but um
they don't inspire a can-do attitude
some of these things should be obvious
to people bubbliness so you
they they try to train people like keep
your arms away from your chest so you're
open and welcoming exposing your
vulnerable soft underbelly is a sign of
trust keep trap keep your legs spaced
apart and be upward on the balls of your
feet and be bubbly and upbeat and never
be sad never be angry
these are the things that they would
they would try and train people for
spread your legs balls out that's all i
heard balls out
yeah because the idea is
if you if you're covering your chest
you're saying i don't trust you i fear
you and that puts them in a sense of
alarm yeah so all of these these
techniques they train on are like base
instinct not even about the words you
say in fact like i mentioned the tall
guy he would barely say words and still
convince people to just give him money
so when it comes to programming humans
we've got base code man we've got an
underlying bios that is easy to exploit
and it's kind of scary i love when
people tell me it's not possible because
i'm like bro marketing exists they they
know how you think
all right let's grab some more what is
this one marks josephine whittaker says
somewhere i heard that when marx died
his wife said if only he spent his time
making capital instead of writing about
it is that true i don't know that's a
good one though it's funny um i mean
that's that's the the necessary burn i
mean i know that that she actually i
mean i've read and there's a wonderful
book
called uh the devil and karl marx by
paul kanger um and he i think i said his
last name right and anyway uh
that sentiment is actually documented i
don't know if that's the the timing but
that sentence that sentiment was
certainly was expressed i remember
reading it we have a correction here
from kurt he says tim the experience for
replica is for the ai not you
the the knot starts off really dumb
but the more you level it the smarter it
gets and it's free to start all right
well there you go
so train your waifu right
your ai replica or whatever
and um and she'll be reading nietzsche
or something to you what if what if like
what if this is really what it is though
the the people who are using this
maybe the idea is like people are lonely
let's give them this ai chat bot but if
people keep communicating it will learn
yeah
they'll take the data what was that
thing that was on twitter and turned
into a nazi and like
two hours that's right microsoft
released a bot that was what was that
called yeah i remember it got
radicalized though yeah it was all the
way it was like imaginary it's it's see
there's a thing about iron man uh
avengers age of ultron like if they were
going to build ultron and this ai they
would put it in a virtual space to see
what would happen first and that's what
happened that's what happened they gave
a nazi right away the chatbot was called
t-a-y that's right that's right became a
nazi instantaneously became a democrat
staffer pretending to carry a tiki torch
outside of a glen yunkan van in like one
hour
that's incredible that's crazy cbs news
all right uh victor says v tubers are
actual people they use 3d modeling
programs to track their face and body
instead of using their actual face this
highlights an even bigger issue with
identity in that some believe they are
their avatar
so they are real people but they're like
technically just puppets i did so
sometimes we've referenced this before
the conspiracy theory pyramid video i
did where it's just my cartoon character
i'm talking about it people were
commenting joking like sheamus is a v
tuber now
dr roller gator is a real gator that
rolls roller skates people don't realize
this but
half the episodes of irl that james has
been on he's actually been a marionette
yeah very good animator i'm a very good
ad very good at it
very talented
all right let's uh grab some more super
chats here and see what y'all are
interested in
okay
daniel christman says marx wrote his
manifesto in 1848. engels trained three
major civil war generals carl schertz
and franz siegel and auguste august
willis marx was the worldwide media
correspondent during the civil war the
civil war was a communist coup
i don't know about all that information
i know that he was in touch with with
lincoln i i don't know more than that on
this subject interesting i've heard that
mighty dork says hey tim did you hear
joe say it was weird saying second
gentleman
is that what he said i don't know he
didn't say it was weird i heard him
saying second gentleman second gentleman
yeah i didn't hear him say it was weird
oh i thought it was weird though
is that joe biden joe biden yeah sorry
mr kamala
yeah her husband doctor jill
doctor elijah zepeda says i don't think
you guys understand how many h games
there are on the internet they all have
patreon pages and make tons of money
just look how much summertime saga makes
a month what is an h game uh hentai is
that what the h is oh is that who's i
don't know waifu i'm in my 40s i don't
know what any other [ __ ] is i mean i
didn't know what it was
i maybe you're right i'm just guessing
it's like it's like what's an h game i'm
gonna look it up inform me something i
probably didn't want to know exists
exactly
okay i will chop it down with my mall
sword yes
all right uh let's uh yeah it's
basically hentai
gross bang
nailed it
jeff jones says first time donator love
you guys shout out to ian for taking
confrontation so well with tim i know
when i am put on the spot i get even
more pissed hahaha gotta learn to enjoy
being wrong
i learned early on when you play video
games with my friends that if you we
would play like you'd win and then the
loser would have to pass the controller
so the winner would stay forever and i
was like why don't we do it where you
play two and you pass it regardless of
if you win or lose so everyone started
to get equal amounts of play time and i
realized it doesn't matter if you were
to lose man we're just playing to have
fun
let's see turkey longwell says how did
coffee become so addictive it's top five
i have no idea coffee it's delicious
because caffeine is an adenosine
receptor uh antagonist and adenosine
makes you feel very uncomfortable when
it gets free and so when you can
antagonize the receptors you can make
yourself feel good all the time in the
famous words of kramer huh wow then you
start to grow more receptors let's just
do uh we'll get one more good super chat
in here jerry let's see arie it's a says
when will you have alex jones on again
he's been on my mind
i need time
uh what if i am alex jones in the james
lindsay suit under the cancer
they would well you see if you took a
whole lot of his supplements
for like brain no
he evolved
so the thing about alex is that um you
know like we went down to austin i was
just like i don't want to have him on
literally every other day you know it's
got to be special make it like make him
a co-host yeah it's like he's just here
no he lives here um but i'd love to have
alex jones on any time and and i think
the most important thing is finding good
guests to have on with alex and also
it's like we've had requests to host
conservatives with vosh and i'm like
look like we we've had the guy in a
couple times i don't want to act like we
are somehow able to connect people and
make these things happen and also
i'd love to have other left
personalities and leftist personalities
on with you know conservatives or
moderates i'm not just gonna be like
there's one leftist who comes on the
show who came on the show twice you know
there's certainly other people we could
bring on and same goes for alex jones
you know there's probably other people
we could bring on too and so we try to
just you know get a diverse eclectic
group so i'll leave it there thanks for
hanging out everybody it's been it's
been a big blast go to timcast.com be a
member if you want to keep supporting
our work and check out our huge library
of members only segments you can watch
the stuff from steve bannon we got alex
jones episodes we got the green room
where you can watch i think we have one
up today
you can see behind the scenes stuff we
had a really really great green room
with magic nawaz because he's downstairs
talking about a whole bunch of stuff
like 40 minutes so it's basically a
whole other podcast so go to guys.com
but don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel you can
follow the show on instagram at tim cast
where we post clips you can follow me at
tim cast for basically shenanigans
twitter just rolled out super follows oh
yeah and so uh they gave it to me and
this basically means that you can sign
up on twitter not saying you should i'm
just saying i'm absolutely going to be
posting things but it's mostly going to
be drama and nonsense something you
would get anywhere else so today i made
a post about how we we actually have a
plan to clone our rooster and i'm pretty
sure i can pull it off if you want to
find out how that's the kind of
shenanigans you'll get on twitter with
super follows or just literally ignore
it who cares you can only come you can
come to the substantive content
naturally that actually matters or you
can you know whatever i figured i'd set
it up uh james wanna shout anything out
yeah i mean i got the new book race
marxism if you can't find it on
the amazon for yourself you can go to
racemarxism.com
website is newdiscourses.com the podcast
there is the new discourses podcast if
you think that i sound kind of smart and
know what i'm talking about with this
mouse stuff i've got tons of hours and
hours and hours of deep dives into this
literature whether it's critical race
theory marxism neo-marxism
post-modernism whatever check it out
you follow me on social media at
conceptual james where people are
probably pissed off at me on the
internet and i am probably laughing
about that fact
lovely i'm seamus coughlin of freedom
tunes we upload a new political cartoon
every single thursday we just uploaded
one about buying state of the union i
think you guys will really enjoy it if
you check it out and we're going to be
doing one i mentioned earlier about the
diversity training requirements for the
military and uh you can check me out
there i love you all jeremiah biden's
campaign speech a little bit yeah
yeah they called it the state of the
union even though he didn't really tell
us much about the state the union was in
yeah i just found that out too i'm
looking forward when you're coming back
i want to talk about heigl's mixing of
self and and other to create god and
then pushing that on society i thought
that plato said like if you don't take
interest in politics politics takes an
interest in you but maybe people have
gone too far maybe that can be something
we look into in the future and yeah talk
more about thanks for coming man yeah
man awesome follow me in crossland.net
peace i always enjoy having james he
mixes a mean aviation which is my new
favorite cocktail it turns out thank you
very much for making me a drink that was
the color of your sweatshirt you guys
may follow me on twitter and mines.com
at sourpatchlinds thanks for hanging out
everybody and uh i guess we'll be back
monday we'll have more shows we'll have
clips of course up throughout the week
so if you subscribe to this channel
we've got clips from like earlier in the
week that are segments you'll see them
here and uh other than that we'll see
you on the next show on monday thanks
for hanging out bye guys
you